It was like you don't trust it,
but didn't start think.
Oh,
Hello Michael.
Hello Joe.
Good to see you,
buddy.
Good to see you.
So this main thing to talk about,
but one of them is why don't you have a
fucking blue check next to your name?
I do on twitter where it matters,
but not on instagram.
Instagram doesn't matter.
Well it does stop.
You're hurting like I've in into shade
the fuck.
I'm just trying to figure out who we
need to contact the sunshine.
The shade everywhere.
What the hell?
Oh God.
God.
Well,
how do they decide who gets a blue check
mark and who doesn't instance the
hardest one?
Really?
Yeah.
What do you have to get?
I wouldn't know Joe.
I wouldn't know.
I don't have an insect blue check mark.
I'm just curious.
It's hurts my feelings.
I'm not even verified on facebook.
I'm A.
Yeah.
Wow.
I'm a pledge.
But you've been on television.
You've published books.
Yeah.
What in the fuck I these people.
This is why we need regulation.
The social media giants.
This is outrageous.
What do you think
about that idea?
That there should be some sort of
regulation like rules as to what
constitutes something that can pull you
off of the social media platform by the
law.
Yes,
but by the law.
That's unconscionable.
It's unconscionable.
Yeah,
but is it constable that someone can
just decide based on their political
affiliation that they don't like the way
someone is talking and pull them off the
plan?
I,
I believe in freedom of association,
which means if you want to dissociate
from anyone at any time,
not only do you can,
you do it,
you shouldn't even have to give a
reason.
It's up to you.
Is that what's happening when you pull
someone off of a social media platform
is just this association?
Yeah,
but there's also.
The problem with that is they're not
being honest and upfront about why
they're doing it.
Right,
so they're being deceptive because
they're saying they're being objective.
If they want to say,
look,
the cost of having this person on
outweighs the benefit.
Okay.
You can wrap your head around it,
but they twitter,
facebook,
twitter especially.
They say,
we're not going to tell you what the
rules are because then people will be
able to exploit them.
It's like,
well,
if you tell us what the rules are,
maybe we can follow them and you don't
have to live in fear.
That is a hilarious way of interpreting
it.
People would exploit those rules.
That's the quote from Jack Dorsey.
That is a ridiculous quote.
Yeah.
What about following the rules?
I mean,
guidelines are supposed to be there so
that you don't step outside of it.
That's exactly right and they're
supposed to that way.
You can also say we're being objective
because it's like we're following these
guidelines that we set that are open.
Do you think
perhaps something that was brought to
them by lawyers with Laura's like
Muslim,
the more you tell them what they can and
can't do,
the more difficult it's going to be to
justify kicking someone off?
No,
I think they have their hardcore agenda
and this way they can cover their
tracks.
I don't think this is the lawyers at all
because then they blamed the lawyers.
They'd say,
legally we have to x,
Y,
and z.
So
you think it's just they have a very
strong political leaning and anything
that deviates from that,
they want to just get removed from the.
I wouldn't say political,
I'd say and philosophical,
but yeah.
Not that they want to,
but they regard as having less
legitimacy.
Do you see the Tucker Carlson show
yesterday?
Yeah.
What?
Of course.
The big victims.
Jim Acosta?
Yeah.
You know,
so there's two scenarios.
One is you're not allowed to come to my
house anymore.
The other one is my house is being
surrounded by the purge,
but clearly the first one is the
nightmare scenario.
Yeah.
Well the Jim Acosta one was strange
because Jim Acosta,
like,
it wasn't supposed to be talking then.
Right,
right.
He was interrupting.
He was deciding that he was more
important than the other person who's
talking.
Right.
And he was also deciding that he was
more important than everyone else in the
room.
And he's also deciding that having a
White House press the grandchild is a
human.
Right.
So basically,
you know,
you could do over your one.
It'll never be taken away,
but there's gotta be some decorum.
Right.
Well,
their argument,
I would guess I can't speak for Jim
Acosta because I could speak in normal
voice,
but they're arguing with that because
the president has made things so lack of
decor and when she has children,
therefore they're following suit.
So I guess that's real leadership,
but this month is really kicking in.
Yeah.
You like it?
Oh yeah.
A lot.
A lot of stuff going on.
Karen got the Taurine it says.
Yeah.
So yeah,
that's,
you know,
it's unfortunate.
I mean,
look,
I think I appreciate the fact that he
goes out of his way to question the
whitehouse narrative when he goes out of
his way.
That's his job.
Yeah.
To,
to put the irons to the president and
get them to answer questions,
but you can't do that while someone else
is talking.
The other guy had the microphone.
You're the guy was supposed to be
talking right here.
Well,
this is why I think he is unforgivable
because during the Singapore summit,
when you had president trump and Kim
Jong Un from North Korea and they're
making,
signing a piece of paper and they're
trying to kind of hopefully go towards a
peaceful direction,
a cost that gets up and yells,
hey,
uh,
what about Ottawa Beer Marshal?
Kim Johnson.
What?
Online beard.
It's like you got this guy who's got 25
million hostages.
He's hold on taking the first step that
dropping his gun.
You're like,
Hey,
what about that kid you killed?
What about a time and a place?
And I don't think Kim Jong Un's speaks
English.
I'm pretty sure he doesn't.
So,
uh,
I think the guy took wrestling a little
too seriously.
Uh,
and I don't know what it is.
I mean,
you know,
a lot of reporters.
I know that our report is,
they don't act like this.
No,
I think he likes attention and I think
he feels like there's something very
significant about what he's doing.
And He,
I think he also wants to be a martyr.
He wants to be a,
you know,
like every like,
he's got the weight of the world on his
shoulders in,
but for him we'd be facing Nazi Germany.
Yeah,
it's,
it's the question is like when does
someone get their press credentials
removed from the White House?
When,
when can they no longer have whitehouse
credentials?
When is,
what is what?
What do you have to do to the point
where everyone agrees you're a nuisance
and you're interrupting regularly.
CNN could just get someone else,
right?
Who's not going to scream out?
It's not like they're trying to block
CNN.
It's like they're to this guy like
you,
you are interrupting like you're yelling
things out and then what?
Have everyone yelled things out at the
same time.
Are you better than everyone else
because you're not.
You're just a person here and if you
just decide,
my opinion in my voice is more
significant than anyone else's will you?
You've thrown everybody else under the
bus the entire rest of the room and the
whole process.
I remember Leslie Stahl had trump on 60
minutes,
not that long ago and you know,
they're going back and forth and she
goes,
Oh,
you know,
well I don't want to talk about that.
I'm like,
this is the fucking president.
You're a reporter.
If he wants to talk about it at the very
least it's going to be the president
says x,
Y,
and Z,
so who are you to be like,
Nigga,
shut up.
We're not going to talk about this.
And he's like,
well,
fuck you.
I'm the president.
So I think there is.
I'm glad this is happening because I
think for a long time the press who has
had an agenda since Washington's days as
they should have an agenda,
pretend that they're honest and
objective and they use the veneer of
politeness and civility to be like,
look,
we're professional,
we're decent people,
but now the mask is dropping and you see
that they're,
you know,
often lunatics.
Yeah,
I was watching this piece on.
I really wish I remember what it was on,
but it was on.
Um,
maybe I was listening to it either way
it was on the news and when the news
started becoming an entertainment
program versus when it was just,
here's the events of the day and this
is,
this is what the,
the significance of these events could
be and this is the impact it could have
on our society.
Instead it just became this really
flamboyant,
wild,
crazy.
If it bleeds,
it leads and it became entertainment and
they really nail it down to 60 minutes.
They were saying when 60 minutes became
a hugely successful financial show,
what's that in the seventies then?
Somewhere around there,
right when was 60 minutes.
It's been around for a long,
long time,
long,
long time.
But when 60 minutes became a hit,
it was a hit show,
like big advertiser money.
It was,
you know,
the entire country would watch it and
then that sort of changed the way they
viewed the news because now they've
viewed the news as a potentially
profitable venture.
And then,
boy,
once I realized that people can clearly
affiliate with one side versus another
side and they want that and their news
coverage,
then you get the Weird Fox News slash
CNN bias,
which is,
it is one of the weirdest polar like
distinctions.
If you watch the news,
you watch television during the
elections particular anything that's
really significant going on.
You go back and forth between.
The two of them were like,
are we just separate universes?
Oh yeah.
Scott Adams has that metaphor which is
that we're looking at one movie screen
and there's two movies in one movie
screen that different people see this
exact same data and see different
conclusions.
And I think that's great.
I mean I think I don't think we need to
be all united.
I think people should like what they
like and the idea that we all got a
great and everything is totalitarianism.
Yeah.
I mean I definitely think that we should
be able to enjoy what we enjoy and
we should lean whatever way we choose to
lean.
I think the issue with the news though
is when it's just straight up
propaganda.
Yeah.
Like when is,
when is this actually the real objective
version of the events or when are they
deleting and editing stuff out and
adding things to concentrating on one
maybe possibly insignificant thing,
but pumping it up to be more than it is
because then it changes the narrative
for their side.
Uh,
this morning I,
I went after some dimwit from Memphis,
from,
excuse me,
from NBC,
and he goes,
this is the worst attack by the White
House and the press freedoms in history.
I go,
John Adams,
second precedent put journalists in
jail.
So did Lincoln.
Lincoln.
Of course you could say it's the civil
war,
but there have been many cases of
attacks on the press.
But of course because everyone is so
narcissistic,
if it's happening to them,
it's the worst thing ever.
And this is basically the gulag even
though they can go on twitter and have
100,000
followers,
I have,
they're good book deals with the
consequences.
Is anybody criticizing Jim Acosta from
the left?
Is anybody saying like,
Hey,
you're not supposed to do that.
Like what you did,
what you did is out of line.
I haven't,
I have,
I've been having fun in La.
I have not seen that.
I think they have been running
interference because I do think that the
press corps,
like any organization you work with,
some of the side by side every day
you're going to be friendly with them
and,
and I do think they,
there is very much obviously acrimony
between Sarah Sanders and the White
House press corps and she's very
insulting and hostile to them and you
could say it's deserved or not.
So of course they're going to kind of
team up together,
be like,
lady,
we're just trying to do our job and
you're just spitting on our face every
single day.
Now the question is,
do these people have,
should have their faces spit it in or
not?
Well,
I think they both suck.
You know,
I think what she's doing sucks.
Like the way she treats people,
like some shoes,
some fucking school teacher in seventh
grade.
That's what it seems like when Sarah's
doing those,
those White House press things.
I Love Venom,
so I love that the venom is flowing in
both directions and the mid like it
because I,
I think people get over politically by
saying let's all get along and then
people who don't get along or
marginalized and those are the ones who
innovate things that the troublemakers,
other ones who move culture and move
politics.
So whenever everyone gets together,
like,
oh,
90 percent of us agree.
Then where fits venom.
It's like,
yeah,
if this country has been at least two
culture since the beginning and it only
stayed one because one conquered the
other and held it under martial law for
decades.
There's no reason for us to be one
United States.
Uh,
when everyone hates each other.
Like,
why?
Let's have a divorce.
What do you mean?
Like just if you want to separate it out
America to different parts.
I think everyone get along a lot nicer.
You do.
You mean like make separate countries
out of America?
Of course like Europe.
Like how,
like if you looked at the size of Europe
and the relative size of countries and
how easy it is to travel from one
country to another,
you can make a real honest comparison
between Texas and New Jersey.
I mean they basically are different
countries,
right?
I mean it's because we all speak
English,
so it seems like we're one we're united
on and like why does this have to be
this way?
Well,
because Texas will start invading.
Everybody can just do that.
Man.
Prison will just steal New Mexico.
Like whose garden it?
That's ours now.
And then they'll just start marching
their way through Phoenix and yeah,
it's a fucking disaster waiting to
happen.
I think this is a disaster that's
happening.
Oh yeah.
And I think the acrimony which I enjoy
on some level because I think it's
honest,
is going to get much worse.
Really.
What makes you think he's going to get
worse?
Because I think both sides are just
doubling down both sides left and right.
Yeah.
I very much doubling down the right has
become radicalized as function of trump.
The left has been radicalized for
decades and there's no look,
here's what happened with capital
hearings.
Either this very innocent family man has
been railroaded completely by shameless
leftist or someone who is quite possibly
a rapist,
was nominated,
was puts us supreme court,
uh,
without being.
And everyone knows it.
So there's no in between and when you
have one event and two completely
obscenely different perspectives,
meeting each side,
sees the others have seen,
I don't see where you get together.
Well,
don't you have a different perspective
on it than either one of those polar
burn it all down?
Nobody been with Kevin.
Uh,
I,
my perspective is I don't agree with the
constitution or regardless Valis I don't
care.
Uh,
I,
I don't know how I would vote if our
center,
to be honest.
Uh,
I don't think she was lying a Dr Ford
obviously sweat.
Nick I think was lying in the one who's
like,
you know,
I went to 10 parties and kept getting
gang raped a,
at a certain point,
you know,
it's just like there was two different
women that had absolutely fabricated
stories that.
But that doesn't mean Dr Ford's
fabricated,
right?
So it doesn't,
but it just shows you that,
that,
that whole zoo can get pretty,
pretty smelling.
I can't imagine any job on earth where
you need to be talking about your
yearbook quotes and I don't run it.
It's just that 30 plus years later,
30 plus years.
Yeah.
So I mean,
and here's the issue with Kevin.
This is why I think it's really unfair.
Uh,
how come they're not asking him to step?
If he had,
why didn't.
No one asked him to step down from.
He was already on the court.
He was just want to supreme court.
If you believed all this stuff,
why don't you ask him to resign,
right?
If this is so serious.
Yeah.
And then on top of that,
why didn't they really,
especially the left,
why didn't they go whole hog into all of
his policy decisions which are much eat
fairer and more Germane.
Now Dr Ford,
I saw her on the side of a milk carton
the other day.
She's vanished.
Like as soon as her purpose was served,
she's gone.
You know,
she probably wants to vanish.
Doesn't seem like she was really
enjoying her.
She wrote that letter in secret and then
there's the whole investigation.
How did this become public?
She's like,
I didn't want this to be public and I
believe her.
She didn't.
I don't think anyone want this
testifying from the Senate in a hearing
like
that where the knives are out.
That's terrifying.
Can you imagine?
There's a few people that would enjoy
it,
but yeah,
to your point,
not her,
not her.
She didn't seem like it and she didn't
see it,
but you know,
I don't think that she was lying either,
but also boy,
wow.
You want to get,
you want to go into what we understand.
We actually understand about the human
memory and you want to stand in front of
many,
many people,
millions worldwide with incredible
consequences on the line and relay
these,
these memories from 30 plus years ago
when you mean you're not even the same
human being as you were when you were 17
years old.
It's just like it's.
I don't even have memories of being 17.
I have memories of things that I've told
about my memories.
I mean the,
you know what I mean,
like you of course you remember the
story teller.
Yeah.
You tell stories of what you remember,
but if I had to like give you the real
solid memories that are unquestionable
about my 17th year of life,
it's fucking shaky shit.
Real shaky.
Obviously nobody tried to hold my mouth
closed,
fuck me on a bed and some weird party
when I was half drunk and I really
wanted to go home.
Not that you remember.
I don't think it happened.
Pretty sure it didn't happen.
No,
but I couldn't,
I couldn't testify.
And in all fairness to her,
uh,
trauma,
if I'm using the word loosely also
things get mixed up and things like
that.
There are people who think she's a
complete fraud and thought she knew she
was going to get money from go fund me
and I'm like,
I don't say it.
That doesn't make any sense to me.
Yeah.
I don't think a 55 year old professor
knows how crowdfunding works.
Yeah.
But you know,
one thing that I did see that was
fascinating though was the,
the,
the university that she teaches a is so
heavily skewed towards women,
like it's almost,
I think it's 70 something percent female
students and a high percentage of uh,
like predominantly female professors as
well.
And their whole thing is social justice
that's there when you know their lists
or objectives as far as education,
like social justice is number one.
It's number one.
It's like the thing that they emphasize
the most,
what's it going to be?
Architecture education.
Sure.
I guess.
But I think universities are there to
promulgate and ideology,
right?
But they literally framed it as social
justice and that does that term today is
so fraught with peril.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
It's the enemy.
It's such a goofy term,
like social justice,
like it,
it's,
so it's such a blanket term and so all
encompassing and you know,
you,
you hear it and you start thinking about
people banging on Tucker Carlson's door
and saying,
we know where you sleep.
That's what I hear.
I mean.
Oh yeah.
No.
And here's,
like I was just talking about just a
couple of ago,
it means 90 percent of people have
agreed that 10 percent or don't agree,
you need to be shut down because we're
talking about social justice.
So the,
there's no such thing as individual
justice because that's subordinate.
Well,
I don't even know what percentage of
people would agree with banging on a
guy's house,
like knocking on his door and saying,
we know where your sleep.
I mean,
did you,
this is a form of mental terrorism,
like you're threatening him.
You're scaring him.
I don't think most people are capable of
empathy by which they mean they can't
put themselves in tucker shoes.
So all they see is someone I hate had
something bad happens.
I him good.
And they don't understand.
Like when these Republicans are saying
that it's okay to torture terrorists.
Right?
And the point I make is there's people
right now,
uh,
Michael,
Ian Black,
or will tell you,
tweet out every day the NRA is a
terrorist organization.
So what happens when the government
defines you as a terrorist?
And then you're gonna say,
well,
it never happened to me that that's not
how it works.
That's the fear.
So you,
we,
if you're going to have principals,
you have to apply them to people that
you hate.
And Tucker Carlson is hardly some Nazi
right now.
Tucker Carlson is,
if you think that he has ideas that are
questionable,
the solution is to present better ideas
and to debate him and to go back and
forth with them.
But Tucker Cross is not leading some
hate mom.
He's not the centerpiece in
Charlottesville for the extermination of
the Jews or he's not that radical.
No,
he's just a right wing guy.
Well,
what they,
what,
what critical theory allows them to do
is to say,
well,
you can read between the lines and
ascribe intent to the person.
Right?
So if you read a book,
you can say,
oh,
this is race because x,
y,
and z reason.
So they can easily say,
well,
when he says a,
B and c,
he means x,
Y,
and z.
So these are all dog whistles and you
can impugn whatever motives you want
onto a person.
And,
and at that point you could do whatever
you want and the thing is,
he's a dad,
so not only you have to be comfortable
with,
with fucking,
with Tucker Carlson's house,
you got to be comfortable with the
scaring as kids.
Yeah,
exactly.
And I think the history of totalitarian
and totalitarianism shows us,
they're more than happy to sacrifice the
kids to get their goal.
It's just really disturbing to me
because I think these idealistic kids
who are doing this,
they're mostly young people have a
fundamental lack of understanding when
it comes to what violence is,
what causes violence.
This is intentional.
And how,
how close that scene was to violence.
Yes,
because you do that to the wrong guys
door.
He's going to come out with a baseball
bat or a gun and he's going to kill some
people or smash some people.
It,
it,
it absolutely can happen.
It's not likely to happen with the
garlic Tucker Carlson.
Well,
what if they decided to go after the
wrong general?
Or what if they decided to go after the.
I mean,
anything can happen in these situations
and also those people are all going to
get outed.
Once those people are out at the outrage
that they're going to experience is
going to be an handleable,
right?
It's going to be unmanageable.
The
the amount of people that are furious at
that group of 20 or what?
How many people was it?
No,
it was plenty.
I'm angry.
I mean I'm not going to do anything but
I think it was disgusting.
If,
if I'm angry,
how many really loosely held people.
People that are just like really barely
keep it in together already,
but here's the scary.
It's not those 20 that aren't going to
have the consequences.
It's going to be people who think like
them who haven't done what they did and
now it's going to be like,
oh,
you agree with this that it's.
I'm going to do it to you.
I think it's going to be them to what's
going to be both.
Yeah.
I think those people don't understand
like people are gonna find their names.
They're going to find where they live
and there's going to be people that have
nothing to do with this,
not Tucker Carlson and it's not them and
these people are going to seek them out
and they're gonna.
It's gonna get ugly.
You can't just bang on people's doors
like that and scare them.
Right?
Because people get furious.
Especially when there's not enough.
There's not enough evidence.
This is not a bad guy.
Tucker Carlson is not some evil demon.
You know,
like if you.
If you looked at who he is and what he
said,
if you pulled out the worst shit that he
said and and taken it in comparison to
the woman that we were talking about
from Msnbc that's still in the air,
Jordan Reed,
who lied about her blog being hacked and
twitter lied just to try to cover up for
the fact that she said some blatantly
homophobic things in the past and called
it and called him the FBI,
which is fucking insane.
That should be a federal crime.
You removing resources right from people
that are already on very serious cases
that are already trying to solve real
real crimes,
save people's lives,
save people's safety,
and you're deciding that your job at
msnbc is more important than that and
she hasn't even fired.
Lauren saw Donald tweeted out not that
long ago,
something akin to regarding to trump if
you're interfering with the FBI,
that should be a federal crime,
and I said she works down the hall.
This,
he's a coworker.
It's like,
what are you talking about?
But because she's African American,
people just stepping away from it.
They're letting it go because they don't
want to be called racist.
I don't know if it's that so much as
people cover their own.
It's a little bit of that,
but they don't always cover their own.
They got rid of Al Sharp.
Not Al Sharpton.
Al Franken,
they got rid of him pretty quick,
but that's the senate I'm talking about.
Like you're still left wing.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
that they're covered.
They're on all men.
MSNBC,
people.
Yeah,
but my.
My point is like the.
I don't know if that lady should be
fired.
I think she should be able to say she's
sorry for shit that she wrote.
That was insensitive.
You know?
I think there's a lot of people like
that.
Brian Williams guy who was completely
full of shit is still in the air.
You don't just lie once about something
like that.
It's probably been line his whole life,
but it's,
it's the degree of the lie.
It's one thing to say,
okay,
I did this.
I did.
That's not going to be like,
you know,
I was getting shot at.
It's like,
I can't imagine.
I was just talking about lack of
empathy.
I can't imagine being in a situation
where I'm on television and I'm saying
things that are so removed from the
truth,
right?
Like I,
I can't wrap my head around that.
Well,
Hillary did the same thing,
but she's a congenital iris as a.
She was referred to by the New York
Times back in the day
and,
and rightly so,
but she.
People forget this.
She did talk about a firefight that she
was in.
It was under sniper fire and the worst
thing about that that people didn't give
a shit about,
she said when she was in Boston,
she was under sniper fire.
It's like,
wait a minute.
We were throwing the secret service and
the bus because what kind of secrets
surface is going to let the first lady
run under sniper fire and there has been
and she just basically did a double talk
around that,
but she's got a lot of whoppers in her
name.
She said she was named after Hillary,
Edmund Hillary.
Even though he climbed Mount Everest
after she was born.
So she's,
she's,
I mean,
amazing.
I love that woman.
I love her so much.
She's the funniest person on earth.
She's a scary lady.
She's like a slinky.
She's always falling down the stairs.
Ah,
yeah.
She's the human slave called dare you.
Yeah,
she's a.
it's an odd duck.
It's,
it's one of those things where women
want a woman to be president so bad.
They want one for the team so bad.
And then there's so many people from the
left thinks she has the best chance of
beating trump or whoever is on the right
that they want her so bad.
They're,
they're willing to exonerate her.
So many different horrendous things.
And one of the things I always point
out,
like people want to talk progressive,
they want you want,
you want to talk,
you know,
being left wing.
And she didn't even believe in gay
marriage until 2013
best part was she was on NPR,
which is this far left far right fringe
organization,
right?
NPR,
Terry Gross.
And Terry Gross says,
used to be against gay marriage.
You know,
your husband passed Doma,
which made it a federal law that gay
marriage won't be recognized by the
government.
Uh,
and you change your position.
Like,
how did that happen?
Was it because Americans became a
hillary?
He's like,
well,
America changed their point of view.
She goes,
no,
I understand Americans change their
point of view.
What was your mental process?
And she goes,
no,
Terry,
you're saying that I changed my mind for
political purposes and that's not true.
And I,
she starts yelling at her and it's like,
Holy Shit,
you're at NPR and you think they're too
right wing for you because they're
calling you out on your bullshit.
You fucking loon.
But the worst part is,
I had one Ito Broderick on my show two
weeks ago and she's the one who accused
Clinton of raping her.
And I asked her who was worse,
Clinton or Hillary?
She said,
Hillary.
She said she's the one who knew what was
going on and let them get away with it.
So that was scary to hear.
Wow.
The thing that got me was when they were
confronting bill recently about Monica
Lewinsky,
and they asked him,
do you owe her an apology?
Right?
And he was like a bed.
But if things that I got out of that
free,
your crazy.
Let me tell you something that I was.
I left the White House millions dollars
yet.
And he stole the furniture and they have
to return it.
And they stole the show.
They looted the White House.
They have to return all the shit they
stole.
Come on.
There's a book called final exit written
by Barbara Olson who died in nine slash
11,
and it's all about they fucking stole
everything.
Really.
All the staff also popped out all the
w's of the keyboards.
So the George Bush office,
people could use them.
Yeah,
they went out there like assholes.
They pop it up.
That's actually kind of.
That was actually kind of funny.
That's a.
that's a a good little.
Fuck you.
Yeah,
but the idea that this guy would in
especially in today's political climate
and dealing with me too and all the
various scandals that have been going
on,
rapist exposed that this guy who if all
that shit was going on today with the
likely either be under indictment or at
the very least under heavy investigation
for sexual assault,
but because it's so long ago,
it seems to be like this weird sort of
gray area that he's saying,
I don't know what her.
An apology you if things that I wasn't
punished like you weren't punished,
like you're worth hundreds of millions
of dollars now.
How?
How are you worth so much money now?
One of the greatest things I remember at
the time,
this has been forgotten,
the press likes to throw this under the
rug,
sweep it under the rug.
They said at first and Monica Lewinsky
was a stocker.
All of Clinton's goons had gotten the
news channels at the time.
Say she's a lunatic,
she's a stalker.
They never had an affair,
and you're sitting there and she's like
23.
How the fuck do you stuck a precedent
that that doesn't make any sense.
If it wasn't for that dress,
let's keep that in mind.
If she didn't have physical evidence,
nothing would have happened to him and
she would be regarded as a loon to this
day and she be treat a complete pariah.
They were ready,
would have never went public with it.
It was that other lady.
She was forced her to go pump.
No,
no.
Ken Starr found her and he.
He subpoenaed her.
Yeah,
but it was because of that woman,
Linda Tripp,
right.
It was her coaxing her to keep the
treasure,
keep the dress,
but go public with this and talk about
it.
He was outed by drudge.
Remember,
was that before that,
before Linda Tripp was doing all this
light fixture and the trip was coaching
her through the whole thing.
Linda Tripp was coaching her privately.
This is all private drudge broke it
because the press wasn't covering it and
they didn't know what to do because this
is a big moment internet history where
they're like,
this website is revealing information
and now we're going to talk about it.
I thought that was also coming from
Linda TRIPP and I thought Linda tripp
keeping the conversations.
Linda tripp was taping the conversations
and I don't know how.
I know drudge was the one who made all
the shit public.
Maybe she was being subpoenaed
privately.
She was going to drudge and she was
leaking and familiar.
Is that true?
Can you look that up?
I don't think Linda TRIPP was linking to
drudge or maybe she was.
I thought the story was A.
I don't know though.
I thought the story was that she was
coaching Monica Lewinsky and trying to
get her to go public with it.
That's possible,
but Monica didn't go public force
throughout the class and she also did it
without Monica's consent.
As far as the record.
That was true and she went to jail for
it.
Didn't she or she was at least arrested.
Something happened.
Yeah,
she was already at very least arrested
for recording and I consent to.
My point was like him sat on television,
like the lack of insight,
the lack of objectivity is his lack of
personal objectivity that he's getting
asked this question,
do you or apology that he can't say,
look,
I made a mistake.
I shouldn't have done it.
Right.
It was a bad thing to do and especially
bad thing to do to a 20 year old girl
and have her exposed like that as close
to my daughter's age.
Yeah,
and for him to not say that is like some
serious sociopathic shit involved in
this.
He's never.
I mean that's his ammo.
He never ever will.
Also,
if you're apologizing there,
you probably legally culpable.
Right.
Because they were going to get him for
perjury.
So Paul and apologies,
that acknowledgement possibly from
Miami,
they pulled this legal license because
of this.
That was part of the deal and left the
White House.
That's right.
I forgot about that.
Yeah,
the whole thing's a mess.
And then.
And then when Hillary is asked about it,
was that a some sort of abuse of power?
She's like,
no,
because they're adults.
Monica Lewinsky was an adult.
Choose a comparison to like fucking
president.
So the only time there's an abusive
power is when children are involved.
Like what the fuck are you talking
about?
It's crazy.
That makes no sense.
But not only that,
that is the biggest is the between an
intern and the later of the world.
Right.
I mean there's no bigger gap,
right?
Forget about like studio executive and
actress,
you know,
like that's,
that's tiny in comparison to the leader
of the world and an intern.
And at the time all the feminist ran
interference for him.
The only one who did it was the craziest
one.
Andrea dworkin.
And she goes,
we know he's a rapist,
Bernita Broderick.
We know that this was sexual harassment,
assault,
sexual harassment,
and everyone's covering for him and you
guys are being complete hypocrites.
It's crazy.
They're willing to do that.
It's tribalism.
I know,
but it's so fascinating when you see it
so blatant and so obvious,
but I mean you see it from the right.
I mean she will experience for them.
Oh yeah.
It's,
I mean it's.
I think it's the human mind convinced it
itself.
It makes double standards.
If I hate you,
I'm willing to believe I know have been
studies about this.
If I hate you,
I'm willing to believe something
negative about you.
If I like you,
I'm willing to believe a compliment
about you and a more resistant to,
to a hearing,
something negative about.
Yes.
And that's just how our brain filters
things.
Sure.
I mean,
we're all guilty of it.
I'm guilty of it with my friends for
sure.
You know,
if someone's mad at my friends,
I'm like,
listen,
it's nothing I can tell you.
Right?
Like,
yeah,
I had seven trying to talk shit on one
of my friends and I said,
there's nothing you can say that's
gonna.
Make me throw him under the bus to you.
Yeah.
So you,
you're just wasting your breath.
Yeah.
There's certain friends like yeah,
they,
they might fuck up,
but they're still my friends.
Yeah,
just to.
I'm not,
I'm not hearing it.
Yeah.
And that's people I know really well.
The real problem with this whole tribal
thing is like it,
it seems to me when it comes to the
political tribes and people are so
invested in winning,
it's so sports like yes,
it's,
it's just so.
It's so strange to see it play out.
It's,
it's disturbing to me also that you
think your life is a function of who the
president is.
Yeah.
And it's just like this isn't,
this is everything's things be good.
Things could be bad.
This doesn't affect you directly effects
you indirectly.
Yeah.
It affects you,
but yeah,
most day to day lives mean hunter.
S Thompson talked about that back the
seventies when he was running for
Sheriff,
uh,
picking county.
He's saying local politics really affect
you,
like that's.
That's something that really changes
your life.
It goes,
but the day to day happenings of the
White House,
most of it is just you're fixating on
these things that really are probably
never going to have any impact,
but local local stuff.
Who's the mayor that has a direct impact
on your life?
What are they going to do with the
streets?
Well,
it's not only the impact,
it's like how much power do you have to
effect change at the local level a lot
at the White House level?
Very little.
Yeah,
and we're seeing that,
which is really one of the really
fascinating things about trump being
president is how much he's trying to do
and how much he's not able to do and how
much pushback there is and how much he
is able to do and how much outrage there
is about it and how much chaos is
surrounding the whole situation.
Yeah,
it's fascinating to watch all the safe
check the checks and balances and the
safety procedures that are sort of built
into the system of government act out
and now that like you see the Senate
controlled by the Republicans and the
house controlled by the Democrats like,
oh Jesus,
this is what I was helping for chaos.
As much cash as possible.
The shit show and it's going to be more
of a shit show in the house with trying
to pick Pelosi's number two.
Yeah.
Well,
and also to see that trump was saying
nice things.
Polosi hilarious.
Trolling the fuck at heart woman.
She does a great job.
I think she really loves our country.
Now that you see what she said,
he goes,
she deserves to be speaker and if the
Democrats won't vote for her,
we'll throw her republican votes.
Wow.
He said that he tweeted it out.
Woo.
Growing up like I'm just going to press
some buttons and see what happens.
They all freak out.
It's amazing.
It really is funny.
You know what I thought was really
hilarious.
I actually enjoyed it when Alec Baldwin
got arrested and they said to trump,
you know,
Alec Baldwin got arrested,
how do you feel?
He goes,
I wish them luck and you know how,
and I tweeted it out and go,
I bet you see an end is going to say
trump refuses to denounce violence in
his hometown.
That's true.
I mean,
the fact that he's.
He's like,
I wish them luck.
I mean,
look,
he just knocked a home,
run out in the parking lot and smashed
every window in the car is parked out
here,
mean with Baldwin getting arrested for
punching someone.
After all those years of him mocking him
on CNN and on a Saturday night live.
It's.
But it's the trump curse.
Like everyone who goes after him,
you know,
they ended up getting destroyed.
Like Ruth Bader Ginsburg.
I mean,
she just fell and broke three of her
hips.
I hope she gets.
Do you think that's a curse?
It's a trump kirby.
The Old Lady just falls down,
but the timing of these things are so
perfect and so like hilariously perfect.
What about stormy Daniels?
Now you've got to pay his legal fees
like that is kind of hilarious that
she's going to pay his legal fees.
You know,
how much strip and you got to do to pay
those legal fees?
His leg.
I don't know.
His legal fees must be through the roof.
They're probably millions of dollars.
I'm.
Yeah,
it's got be crazy.
right?
Sure.
Yeah.
I mean he has an enormous legal team.
They've been.
And then how about all these people that
we're going to turn and I'm like Michael
Cohen,
now he's fucked.
What is he going to do now?
What is he going to say?
You?
Well,
we already know that you paid her off
and now no one cares because he just won
the case.
Right?
And so she has to pay his legal fees and
now you're stuck with nothing.
You have nothing.
Right.
And now he always tried to say a trump
saying,
I'll trump used racist language with me.
It's like,
really?
Okay.
Well they're supposedly that Mike,
Mark Burnett tape.
Okay.
Yeah.
Tom.
Tom Arnold,
trying to find it.
Right.
That's the APP.
Mark Burnett,
the guy is that Mark Burnett?
The survivor guidance apprentice guy,
apparently very religious.
Okay,
and he is inclined to support trump's
positions on many things and he's just
not going to release that.
No,
no.
There's no way.
Trump who is running a TV show.
We look at t look at Megan Kelly joined
reed.
He's.
If he's using racial slurs in front of
cameras and a cast of 50,
which I'm sure are going to have people
of color.
This is New York.
There's no way this wouldn't have leaked
at the time.
That's not true.
If he's using the n word.
No.
If there's.
If there is a.
there's a sound guy and there is a
producer and they're collecting tapes
and everyone has.
No,
no.
If he's doing this publicly in front of
all,
he's not doing it publicly.
He's talking to someone and it was
recorded much like the billy Bush thing
when he was on the bus.
Right.
It's kind of doing it publicly,
but he's talking to somebody.
I thought he was talking to one of the
cast members supposedly does somewhat.
I heard this tape is big foot,
big foot.
It's like a small,
like hang on 18,
but at the other thing is if he's using
this language,
he would have been using it frequently
was he does hit certain words over and
over.
Yes,
but it could be.
He used it in a very specific way.
Like you know the story about the guy
from Netflix,
right?
Or here's how about the story about the
hub of John.
John got.
Yeah,
that's outrageous.
We'll we'll explain it to people that
don't know.
The store was on that conference call
with a PR firm,
the PR firm,
and he said he was saying,
we're not going to be like Colonel
Sanders saying Blah Blah Blah with the n
word.
He was quoting somebody else as an
example of don't use this kind of
speech.
It's really bad.
And they go,
Oh,
you invoke that word.
You're fired.
Literally,
and he is the CEO of the company and
he's saying to them,
we're not going to use these words.
We're not going to be like these person.
Like,
it's not like saying Michael Richards.
like if I said that like,
Hey,
I'm not going to be like Michael
Richards and get on stage in front of
everybody and drops men bombs and people
just start freaking out.
Joe Rogan just said the warrant and then
all of a sudden that becomes public and
then I get fired and then youtube pulls
me off and then itunes pulls me off.
Literally.
That's what it's like.
What happened with the Papa John's.
But all anybody hears is the Papa John's
guy said racist shit.
No,
no,
no.
That's all they.
All they heard was papa John's refused
to support Colin Kaepernick.
And now they're like,
all right,
we're gonna get this fucker.
And they did.
That's part of it too,
right?
Yeah,
that's part of it too.
Yeah.
There was a,
there was already a,
uh,
an agenda,
right?
Because of refusing to support
Kaepernick.
Gee,
this is the whole thing is just,
it's the.
And then there's the Netflix guy.
Do you know the Netflix Guy?
I don't think I know this one.
What is his name?
Well,
it doesn't matter.
There's a gentleman who was like,
one of the top dogs at Netflix says,
you shouldn't say the word retard
because two people that have someone in
their life that has down syndrome.
It's like using,
and he doesn't say the n word,
he says nigger in front of African
Americans and he says this in a room
filled with people and some of them
happen to be African Americans.
How many of them were retarded?
So they freak out that he's used this
word saying that it is just as offensive
as using the n word,
but he's.
He's a false equivalency.
They're saying like,
this is much worse.
No,
no,
no.
He's just using it in terms of saying,
this is about my friend Tom,
my friend Tom Segura has a bit in his
last Netflix special and the bit was
about you can't use the word retarded
and this is what he says,
and he goes into all these different
words that you can't use anymore.
And because he said Tom stole this from
George Carlin.
No,
that's the George Carlin bit though.
How?
What is it?
The seven words.
You can't stand television now.
They've done.
Yeah,
it's very,
it's very different when he's saying he
has a whole,
it's a very good bit,
but it's in no way endorsing using that
word so.
But the fact that he uttered it out loud
with this guy was saying was this is the
same thing as someone uttering the n
word out loud,
but he didn't say the n word.
He said Nigger,
and because he said that they fired him
from Netflix.
Wow.
Literally saying a noise to represent a
word that's an offensive word,
and this is.
They said enough is enough.
You said Abracadabra,
that is gone.
That is a retarded decision.
Is it niggardly?
All of they're saving money.
That's a different word that people are.
People are saying you shouldn't say to
anymore because it sounds too much like
the n word,
even though it means stingy.
Right.
Which is very funny.
Oh,
Jesus.
But it's,
it's moises.
It's not.
It's not about intent anymore.
It's just about never been about
attendance about domination.
Right.
It's always about domination.
That's one thing that Carlin said.
That's absolutely correct.
It's political correctness is just
fascism with better language.
Yeah.
It's all about domination and telling
the line and you know,
picking off the people that you need to
pick off and making examples.
I then for everyone else,
yes.
What it.
No,
he didn't say better language that
fascism disguised as being polite or
something like that,
but the fact that they felt like it was
a smart decision to just fire someone
because he said annoys you should.
What you should say is like,
I understand what you're to say,
but let's just not use that word.
Yeah,
you're right.
Done not no more job.
You,
you do bad work.
You're done.
No more income.
Public shaming.
Get out of here.
And the people that were in the room
were the ones that turned him in.
There were some African Americans
apparently that heard him say that word
out loud and they just saw it as a green
light and they just went after him,
Huh?
Well,
I made at the same time,
you have to wonder if those executives
are living in fear.
Of course they said know they're like,
shit,
we better do something really quick
because now the.
Now we're going to have lawsuits.
There were boycotts and blah,
blah,
blah.
Well,
the Roseann thing,
they trigger and now do you know how
much money is that?
You can't say anymore.
It sounds too close.
That was my last special.
No,
you can't say.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
but you can't say that word like it
sounds too much.
Like the analyst got to really emphasize
that the er,
um,
when the Roseanne thing happened and
they,
they immediately stepped up and you
know,
this is a warrant.
We hate racism.
You're fired.
They have lost so much fucking money.
That show is hemorrhaging money and this
return,
the connors has done terribly.
The audience,
not just half the audience,
but half the audience and then shrinking
every week and it's most likely being
canceled.
But this is what I think people don't
get a ostensibly the point of,
of businesses to make money.
That's why people go into business for a
lot of people.
It's not the people running these
organizations are there to further.
There are cultural ideology.
Yeah.
So the profit will be secondary to
cultural acceptance.
Well,
cultural acceptance comes along with
future profitability.
Yes,
the lack of cultural acceptance could be
financial devastated.
I think that's,
that's the way they're looking at it,
part of it,
but part of it there also.
Look,
if you go to,
if you live in New York and then you go
to a lefty school and then you become an
executive and your entire culture is
this lefty worldview,
you're gonna think this is how all right
people,
right thinking people act.
You're going to act in a certain way
accordingly and not even have
consideration for any possible other
side.
That's a good point.
That's a good point,
but it's fascinating that she was not
allowed to apologize.
Roseanne was not allowed to apologize,
but that woman from Msnbc joined was who
said much,
much more awful things.
Roseanne was near.
I think she was hysterical or near tears
that day because she's like,
I care about the crew.
They're the ones who are getting fucked
please.
Like,
I'll do what I want.
I'm not,
you know,
and that's why she let the show go on
without her and she didn't fight it.
Right.
And,
and Kudos to her.
Yeah.
She's,
she's a friend of mine and she's an
awesome person.
She really is.
She adore her.
She's not what anybody is trying to
paint her out too,
but let's talk about tribalism because I
remember you remember not that long ago
when her show was on,
she had that whole Brouhaha with the
national anthem.
Oh yeah.
Now the Republicans are out for blood
and now all of a sudden they love her
and the memories are very,
very short.
I love her because she's controversial
and speaks her mind in both cases.
Well,
she's also legitimately mentally ill.
Had a terrible car accident when she was
15 years old.
He was institutionalized in a mental
institution for
nine months afterwards.
Like it has personnel,
personality,
multiple personality disorder,
trauma induced multiple personality
disorder,
has been on a host of medications or
whole life.
Because of that.
Like my analogy that I say is a asking
her to behave normally.
It's like asking a person with a broken
leg to not limp.
Yeah.
Well,
and the other one thing against her that
you can say she did accused both her
parents of molesting her and she laid
later,
I don't want to speak for her,
but I think she
track that a little because they denied
it completely.
I don't remember that,
but I wouldn't be surprised dude.
She got brained by a car when she was
15,
like smashed.
I did not.
Some woman was driving through an
intersection,
couldn't see because the sun glare in
the window and clipped her with a car
and she was fucked up.
I mean she was,
she went from being a straight a student
to being someone who could no longer do
math.
She detailed it like really emotionally
and very honestly and vulnerably.
She was very vulnerable.
And in discussing it on my podcast,
it was really good.
Gary,
she,
she's done such a big heart to eight
really is very,
very obvious whenever she talks and
she's on twitter and she's super funny.
Uh,
I,
I mean I'm a big fan of her twitter and
do it in that
things that she said about that woman,
you know,
being a marriage of this planet,
of the apes,
you know,
like not the worst thing to say.
And The lady looks like the lady from
the planet of the apes.
I don't give a fuck what you say that
does that even though she was black,
I thought that bitch was to write things
that she was Jewish.
She looks like my sister,
she's running the government,
she must be Jewish.
I thought the thing that's great about
Roseanne is she was on,
I think Tucker Carlson,
Sean Hannity and she looked and he's
like,
do you want to apologize to Valerie
Jarret?
She looked the camera.
She goes,
Valerie,
on genuinely sorry,
I did not want to hurt you.
This was not acceptable.
But I also do think you need a better
haircut.
You know,
like she still had a joke in there,
but she's such a sweetheart and,
and I don't think the thing that I have
people arguing with me about when I,
Valerie Jarrett was born in Iran and
people were like,
well,
she's not black.
She was born in Iran.
I'm like,
you know,
black people can give birth in Iran.
Right.
That's the thing.
And this was rapid.
They couldn't wrap their heads around
it,
that she was black,
but in Iran her parents were American,
right?
Yeah,
yeah.
The whole thing's a mess.
But it's also one of those things.
It's fiercely tribal.
You said before,
and then our tribe,
the tribe of the left of the tribe of
the right,
our tribe is decided.
Your tribe is it acceptable,
unacceptable.
And what you've done is just beyond the
possibility of any sort of apology you
need to be removed even at a significant
financial loss.
And apparently the people that were
responsible for getting her fired,
one of them has already been removed.
Oh yeah.
And um,
now they're realizing there was a
horrendous decision.
They went from having the number one
show on television to having this
bastard version,
the Hogan family.
It's fucking terrible,
man.
And nobody wants it.
So they,
if they just decided bring her back
and she apologized and everyone sued
that over and look,
there could be money donated to
charitable causes.
It could be a teachable moment or a
learning moment for,
for everybody,
for the whole country.
Uh,
a moment also of like,
like of bonding where we just abandoned
these ridiculous ideas.
There was an episode I watched the
series a,
it was like episode six.
Her neighbors that moved into the house
from Lanford were Muslims and Roseanne
was prejudice.
And then she realized she was wrong.
There was an episode that's like,
stop being.
So she's always been very culturally
left.
Yeah,
she,
she is in some ways and she's right in
some ways she's,
she leans right in some ways.
She's very pro Israel,
like super.
So much so that she could have even
talked about moving to Israel.
Yes.
Yeah.
Because,
I mean,
I think she,
I think she feels I can't speak for her.
So yeah.
Well the whole.
But what do you got here?
Jamie is their rating is actually pretty
good.
It's the number to show overall and ABC
and it's their top rated comedy.
It's down from where it was obviously,
but getting to 10 million.
What are you getting this from?
We're getting this from vulture.com,
which is a very left leaning show and
it's probably will go to the title of
this.
Go to the title of all TV shows right
now.
Yeah.
Market brand.
Good Lord.
What?
Yeah.
What's that about?
[inaudible] back to life.
Yeah.
But the ratings are significantly lower.
More than 50 percent lower than they
were with the other show.
True.
But it was also extremely an extreme
hit.
Right.
But it's the same show,
Jamie.
Okay.
There's no way you're going to tell me.
Fifty percent is not a problem.
Yeah,
but that's the problem.
You reading a spin,
what you're reading is vulture spin on
it that says it's not that bad.
They're circling the wagon.
Not only is it not that bad,
they did 10 episodes,
they ordered an 11th.
That's unprecedented.
What you order is,
look,
when I was on Sitcoms,
they would do a thing called the back
nine,
right?
So you would get 13 episodes and they
would order the back nine,
which would bring you to 22,
which is a full order.
They're not doing a full order.
This shows dead,
right?
So it ain't good.
And the other thing is,
keep in mind this show is extremely
expensive because you've got to pay.
Laurie metcalf was probably the best
comedic actress out there.
Three hundred thousand.
John Diamond gets more than $300,000.
Given Sarah Gilbert,
he gets more than think.
You've got the others too and have a
million dollars right away just with
three members of the cast.
Then you have production fees,
all these other different fees.
There must be a billion eps in that
show.
It's crazy money.
It's crazy money and it could be the
biggest show on television.
If she was still on it and,
and the apology was accepted you,
you're not going to lose viewers.
They could have easily done an episode
where they were.
The character did that.
It gets clouded as an asshole.
Yes,
100 percent they could have done it
where they're interviewing her outside
of the polls and she says that TV for
television.
Yeah,
they say she says it on television and
then she gets labeled as a racist and
then a bunch of people say what she
really does look like.
That lady.
That will be how it had data.
It would end with them coming home.
Dan close the door and goes there.
She really does look like that the whole
thing.
But I didn't know she was black and like
how could you not know?
And then they showed different people
that look black that aren't black and
different people that look white,
but our black pull up Dan Berninia Bon
gee.
I know he's on Fox all the time.
He's Italian and he has to say on
twitter,
I'm not black.
I don't know who this guy as you'll see
his picture.
It's just like you go to 23 and me
because I'm Italian too,
but I did my ancestry.
I'm one point six percent African.
Oh,
okay.
Know which is so much more than
Elizabeth Warren is Indian.
So much more.
Yeah.
Oh,
that guy's black.
He's male.
He's Italian.
No,
don't.
don't lie to me.
It's true.
That's a black man.
If that guy just gets at the hair.
Listen Bro.
That guy is so African.
No,
he's an Italian.
Well,
listen to Italian.
First of all,
depending upon what part of it.
The Morris.
Yeah.
Oops.
I mean he probably had some,
but also Italy,
just if you look at how close Italy is
to northern Africa,
it's very close.
Like people just came over.
They,
they,
they fucking fucked around.
They were real close to each other.
They got on boats,
they went back and forth at long
distance relationships.
I mean the Italians in particular,
especially northern Africans or an
African.
They're not black.
They're Middle Eastern.
Yeah,
right.
Yeah.
But it is still Africa.
Sure.
Yeah.
It's African genetics when also Egypt.
Egypt also had a relationship with a
newbie.
EONS and eons eventually conquered Egypt
and Ethiopia is too.
Yeah.
So it's a lot of,
there's a lot of.
Lot of fucking gone around.
Wait,
so what else were you in your eye?
I'm 99 point eight.
I need the Jewish or white.
There's like nothing else in there.
I'm,
I'm mostly Italian.
Um,
and the,
the other percent is Irish,
but it also could be English.
It's one of those,
you know,
your,
you're but it's Irish,
which is where Rogan comes from.
Um,
one point six percent African and then I
think there a small amount of Asian in
there as well.
No small amount of Asian,
like one percent plus or minus Asian.
Yeah.
No,
native American.
Yeah.
Unfortunately I love her to still
probably have more than Elizabeth
Warren.
The best thing that I.
This boring stuff.
There's two things I love about that.
She takes this test in secret and of
course I wonder why,
but no,
but she took a secret.
Then she revealed it.
She could have seen the results.
You're like,
Oh fuck,
I'm not going to talk about this because
she thought it might say zero.
Right.
And because it said zero,
zero,
zero point one.
She was not even native American.
It was South American.
She did like a,
a,
like Brazilian jeans or whatever it was.
Next skin genes.
Is that what it is?
Yes,
it wasn't native American genes,
they didn't find native American DNA to
match number one the best.
Here's the best part.
Trump per year for two years like
Pocahontas,
but guys,
when are you going to take the test?
She goes,
I took the test by the fuck.
He goes,
who cares?
Just walks away.
He's like each.
Well,
she said that he was supposed to pay a
million dollars towards charity because
she took the test,
but if that's the case and the test
actually shows South American genetics
and not native American church,
well isn't that.
That's all very squirrely too.
It's like what is native American?
I mean there's,
there's so many similarities between
people from Mexico and native Americans,
people from Ecuador and native
Americans,
Peru.
I mean there's extreme similarities
between what we think of as traditional
native Americans and then people that
lived in South America and then also the
actual path that they got here in the
first place.
A lot of them have Siberian genetics.
Sciatic,
yeah.
Yeah.
I mean that's what's really.
Did you know the whole story behind how
that got discovered?
No.
It was a guy who was a mormon,
is about a decade plus ago,
who was trying to prove this Mormon
doctrine that Jesus,
Jesus is lost tribe came the the lost
tribe of Israel America,
and these were the native Americans,
so this guy,
and this was when DNA tests were
insanely expensive.
This guy spent a shitload of money to
try to test native Americans to try to
find Israel like jeans and he found that
they have Siberian jeans because I came
across the bering land bridge,
which was excellent because it really
did prove that theory that people did
migrate on foot through the,
through the bering land bridge.
It's just so silly,
but if you look at like,
like native Americans and then you look
at like some Mexicans,
you go,
wow.
That was a distinct similarity between
these two in terms of their features are
coloration's like how they looked?
Oh yeah.
I mean they're.
They're going to evolve the similar
climates and things like that.
Yeah,
and I think probably similar origins of
ancestors,
you know,
and so she's got a point south
Americans,
she's amazing.
She's amazing.
I think she's on the spectrum too,
probably,
but the number of percentage that she
has of this gene is so fucking small.
One,
1000,
24th.
That is so small.
I'm one point six percent right.
That's literally like what?
Like ten one hundred times as much as
her.
I think she's pointed.
Oh six.
So you're like 30 times as much as 30
times as much African as she is native
American and.
But yet she used that to get a job at
Harvard.
The funny part is she had contributed
recipes to a book called Powwow Chow,
not making it up and she signed it.
Elizabeth Warren Navajo.
But here's the.
Here's the kicker.
She plagiarize the recipe.
Oh my God,
that's beautiful.
So not only was he not a fucking native
American,
it's like a crab salad recipes,
like what native Americans are eating.
Fucking crab.
The fuck you're from Maryland.
Yeah,
the Maryland Baltimore runs Tuesday.
So it was Ryan sickler would say,
wow,
that is crazy.
That is just,
it's one and.
But,
but again,
because she has potential in terms of
like she's a strong woman,
she's articulate,
she's very well educated.
She's been a professional politician for
a long time.
People on the left are not denouncing
her.
Yes,
they have.
Oh.
Some people were like,
okay,
this,
that.
There were articles that go,
okay,
this did not go as we planned because
they were just like this as genetics
test.
Yes.
And a lot of people are uncomfortable
with her appropriating set asides that
are for people who are actually
suffering minorities.
He'd be like,
no,
this is not cool.
So she's gotten pushed back from small
blogs.
I'm not seeing this from anything
mainstream.
Correct.
Because mainstream,
they're always going to cover for the
establishment.
That's been 100 percent of the time.
Yeah.
They're going to cover about those blogs
is like,
a lot of them are basically like Ari
shaffir refers to him as like college
papers.
It's like a lot of these blogs or like
college student written yet,
but they're often speaking truth.
Oh yeah.
Well,
I would hope,
I would hope more would come out and
say,
hey,
you can't say you're native American.
Just like,
like imagine the outrage if I just
started calling myself African American.
Well,
do you know what?
Did you see what trump said?
He said,
well,
I can't call her pocahontas anymore
because she's not an Indian.
And I'm just like,
oh my God,
we're not worthy.
He says some hilarious shit.
Oh yeah,
he really does.
He really does.
He's fucking funny off the cuff.
Oh yeah.
It really is.
You know,
and the way he goes after people,
like,
even though he's the president,
like he still calls people fucking
losers.
I mean he's still,
he's still caused them losers on twitter
and goes after them.
The horse face face,
he called stormy Daniels horseface.
Just think of how repulsive he is
physically.
He's fat is faces off fucking hanging
off of his bones.
He's got white raccoon eyes,
an orange skin,
and yet he's still will mock stormy
Daniels and call her horseface.
Someone tweeted out,
I forgot who,
and I apologize the thing he said,
they go,
imagine what happens.
That trumps the first person who fucked
a porn star and she had to brag about it
and then she paid him.
She has to pay him now.
Yeah.
Well he did pay her.
Right.
But what he paid her,
what she's going to have to pay him is
probably like a factor of three or fours
when you.
I mean how much more she's going to wind
up paying him for 350 k.
that's all you asked for it.
Oh,
that's a very reasonable.
And that doesn't even cover her book.
It's probably like he just wants to just
get it.
Just give me that paper.
Just gave me a little something.
I need a little something from you with
this.
Let this slide.
I want 300,000.
Yeah.
That's probably a whole book.
That's probably all the money know she
got more than 3:50
on positive.
How much she thinks she got from that
book?
A 750 guess.
Yeah.
But she's got to pay taxes.
Sure.
I know agents getting 15.
Yeah.
She's probably not even bringing three
home.
So it's all that money's gone.
Oh yeah.
That's all gone.
All gone.
One hundred percent gone and no one's
buying that book.
Step four,
get stiffed.
Yeah.
Nobody gives a shit.
She said it all already.
Like,
I fucked the president.
That's your book.
Your book is.
I fucked the president.
Like,
you know,
here's the funny part with her.
I do remember this.
People,
she was making fun of his Dick,
like had hit a mushroom deck,
whatever.
And people were like,
that's what she said.
And then people were like that,
you know,
that as fucked up as he is.
That's body shaming.
You really shouldn't make fun of seven.
And she's like,
you know what?
You're right.
I'm sorry.
And then he goes,
hey horseface.
She goes his fucking mushroom deck at
like the next day she's back on it.
It was amazing.
The fact that he can call her a horse
face towards his face.
No,
it doesn't matter.
I know,
but it's just so weird for me.
Ted Cruz really isn't the unabomber or
whatever the fuck he said he was going
to say that.
That's the name he said.
He said that shot JFK.
It's fucking.
It's also crazy.
That was the best part.
So Ted Cruz's what was known as like the
best debater in the Senate.
He had this Harvard,
Yale,
whatever,
debating team,
great debater.
Everyone recognized him with this.
How the fuck do you prep for a debate?
Be Like,
Oh yeah,
well your Dad Jeff Gfk.
It's like,
what the fuck?
Wait what?
Fuck.
Well,
it didn't have to make sense.
Right?
People,
people that are trump supporters don't
want it to make sense.
They just want them to win.
Right,
right.
Exactly.
And it works.
Yes.
Yeah.
Well he just had a good zingers in.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
I mean it's like roast battle more than.
And they don't get that.
There was this girl my favorite tweet of
his,
my favorite,
where he goes whenever I speak of the
losers and the haters,
I do so with great affection.
It's not their fault.
They were born fucked up.
That's a real trump tweet.
It's the,
you know,
one of my favorite things was him at a
speech where he was talking.
It was 2015 before you even talked about
running for president or he was even.
I don't think he was 100 percent open
about running for president and he said,
there's two ways to talk to China.
You could,
you could propose things,
and he says it like,
you know,
normally,
and then he says,
or you could say,
listen,
motherfucker.
Yeah.
You ever heard that?
No.
Oh my God,
it's great.
Fucking pull it.
It's fucking great because everybody
starts cheering.
Yeah,
because it's so forbidden in this
environment wearing an expensive suit.
Standing in front of a podium.
He says,
or you could say,
listen,
motherfuckers like this is what we're
going to do,
and everybody's tired.
It's so exciting.
It's so much more exciting than Marco
Rubio or you know,
someone.
Boom.
Jab,
jab is a waste.
Janis and big fat mistake.
Oh wait,
did it with the fingers.
I watched those.
Which reach because he kept his waist
June of Twenty 15.
Now when he said,
motherfucker,
when he just just not speech when he's
talking about China and he said,
listen,
you fuckers China China chain.
Yeah.
That was a thing.
Puerto Rico.
When Puerto Rico,
I'm announcing a ban on all Muslim
immigration and Muslim here.
This is a great.
Well listen to this because it's
leadership this time instead of with his
name and gold,
it's with his words.
Is this discussing Iraq?
We build a school,
we build a road.
They blow up the road,
they blow up the school,
we build another school,
we build another road.
They blow them up.
We build again.
In the meantime,
we can't get a school built in Brooklyn
to the audience approval talking oil.
We have nobody in Washington that sits
back and said,
you're not going to raise that price.
You understand me?
This is a long time ago saying Chinese
goods and your mother.
We're going to tax you at 25 percent
while poles 11.
Is that what it says over there?
At least when it's posted,
but here's what's interesting.
Notice the person who posted it,
their name is say no to racists.
Oh yeah.
They probably put it up as a negative
thing.
Well,
no,
2011.
He would have been considered a
Democrat,
right?
Oh No.
He's endorsed Romney.
He dressed Romney.
Republican budget.
Regardless of race,
he was a Democrat until what?
Twenty 10 probably around then because
he was gonna run as an independent at
some point.
Trump 2012.
Look at that.
This is the guy we've been looking for.
Wow.
Seven years ago,
but it's just deplorable.
Changed it.
They probably wouldn't be good.
Changed it in the future because it says
seven years.
Yeah.
Fuck that traveler deplorable.
That's the time travel that had joined
read.
Uh,
yeah.
Someone did it.
Someone definitely hacked it.
Yeah,
just hilarious.
They didn't give the good version of
that either because they believed it.
Well not just that,
because he also see if you can find the
better version because he,
he basically prefaces it like,
you know,
people have been saying it like this,
right?
You could say it like this or you can
say,
listen you motherfuckers.
And that's when everybody starts
cheering.
He actually gave an example of how he
actually go ahead.
What can you do?
Yeah.
So easy.
I'm dropping 25 percent tax on and you
know,
I said to somebody that is really the
Messenger.
The Messenger is important.
I could have one man say,
when did he text you?
Twenty five percent and I can say
another.
Listen,
you mother.
I know he wouldn't have the press lies
on the campaign trail.
He said a point.
I remember what it was.
The sense that he goes,
you better shut your mouth.
So he didn't
say the word [inaudible].
They bleeped it and they believed it to
make it look like he was cursing.
And he's like,
you guys are fucking shady as hell.
That's very shady.
Yeah,
that's true.
You can't just bleep a pause and pretend
that there's some sort of on the fence
of word in there.
Right.
So that's really,
that's just deceptive.
Right?
And it's pervasive.
They do it all the fucking time.
Well,
who's good out there to challenge him?
They're fucked.
Fuck.
You know why they're fucked.
Because we've never had this happen
before.
The whole time.
All those Democrats are fighting each
other for the primary,
for the nomination.
He's going to be tweeting the shit out
of those debates.
He's going to be live tweeting the
debates and they're not going to have to
worry about the tax from their
colleagues,
but also from the sitting precedent was
like,
look at this dope and he's going to come
up with nicknames for them in the stick.
Denang Dick.
He already did.
Oh my.
It's amazing.
Bang.
Dick Dick Blumenthal.
Senator from Connecticut,
lied about his Vietnam Service.
Has started calling him Denang Dick.
He lied about his Vietnam Service.
They've got elected.
Whoa,
shameless.
Yeah.
How did he lie?
What did he say?
He said he served and he didn't look it
up.
Yeah,
I mean it's,
it's,
it is brazen.
It wasn't some ambiguous area.
I think he's like,
he never left America as my
understanding.
Oh yeah.
And he said he was in nom.
And then he's fucking going after Kevin.
Oh
God.
How does he get away with it?
But how do they all get away with,
uh,
Dennis Hastert was speaker of the house.
Dennis Hastert was speaker of the house
and he fucked how many kids?
I mean the wrestling team.
And he only went to jail for 15 months
for it.
Yeah.
He went to jail for 15 months because of
the statute of limitations or something
ridiculous.
Well,
I think then you go to jail for lying
about paying them off.
I said,
yeah,
yeah.
That,
that isn't saying he's out now,
which is just insane and it's no one
talks about him,
which leads me to think there's plenty
of this and both sides of the aisle.
Well,
there must be.
He must know where the bodies,
right?
Of course you're speaker of the house.
They just got to.
They're just going to say,
listen,
15 months,
not that big a deal with Russia.
Cakewalk in jail.
It's okay,
we'll get your books.
It'll be fine.
That's as foreign.
And one will not only that,
like when did he stop fucking kids?
Right.
That's the real question because that
is,
that's a sickness that just doesn't get
cured.
Right.
It's not like quitting cigarettes or
something like that.
The recidivism rate for people that are
molesters is insanely high.
Right.
So who knows.
Look,
that was one of the creepier things.
That was it.
Drudge.
That said,
or was it Breitbart?
That's,
I think it was bright.
That said before he died,
where he's talking about Podesta.
I.
This was the one issue I had with legal
from my forthcoming book because I,
because drudge said how the tweets still
up dried says how John Podesta is not
known as an international like child
Marissa coverup or completely eludes me
and no one said anything at the time.
It wasn't a big deal.
Podesta never sued and what he might
have been referring to is Robert Epstein
with pedophile island where
guys all go to like Jeff Epstein.
Excuse me.
Jeff Epstein.
Yeah.
To go that island Clinton's gone like
nine times and you fuck all these
underage girls,
but then they took it to be as proof of
pizza gate or something like that.
Yes,
but here's the thing.
Here's Breitbart or wasn't breitbart
entered bipolar tweet,
but if you look at drudge,
Breitbart,
drudge,
let's Breitbart,
breitbart.
So if I said to Roger,
I apologize,
just one of those,
but here's,
here's the other thing.
It's that everyone knows historically
that young women went to Hollywood and
had to do sexual favors.
If,
since the twenties in order to get their
career head right,
this is very known.
Yeah.
Why wouldn't this happen with young men
with a older guy executive's why would
there be any difference?
Well,
most certainly of course,
but they like to pretend that,
you know,
this is all crazy.
It's all a conspiracy.
It's like,
why,
you know,
it's true with this one.
Well,
because it's so blatant and it's so
prevalent that it's horrifying,
right?
Because then it's also the powerless and
it's like,
what am I going to do about it?
Yeah.
And just knowing how much it did happen
and if they did just uncover every
single instance of it.
And that's the other thing.
It's just like with,
with a,
um,
Harvey Weinstein,
how everyone knew,
we all knew and they all knew about
Clinton and all this stuff.
It's like,
who knows who's a and who's when you're
looking up the other way when it comes
to kids that's so,
uh,
beyond the pale.
Yeah.
Let's start.
Shit,
it gets very dark there.
So this Denang Guy,
Denang Dick W,
he.
So what did he actually say and what was
the.
I don't want to misquote him.
A Dick.
Richard Blumenthal from Connecticut.
How the fuck did he get reelected?
Connecticut's influenced because it's
tribalism.
You're gonna vote blue in Connecticut,
but how would,
how would they accept him as their
candidate?
Because he got.
I think it came out once he was the
candidate.
Oh Jesus Christ.
Yeah,
that's a big one man.
Yet is so invalid and all that stuff.
I mean,
forget about what Brian Williams did.
That's way bigger.
I get shit for having shaved sides of my
hair for like,
is that the Nazi?
No,
they're like,
is that stolen valor?
And I'm like,
no,
I've got that.
Yes.
Come on a haircut.
I'm politifact.com
about it.
He listened to the Marine Corps reserves
in 1970 and told him five deferments had
kept him out of the war,
getting a coveted slot in the reserves,
reduced the chance of battlefield
deployment Blumenthal.
Went through basic training and served
six years in the Washington dc area in
Connecticut.
As Connecticut's Attorney General
Blumenthal.
Regularly attended Memorial Day parades
and other events at recognized soldiers
and veterans in New York Times wrote and
May Seventeenth,
2010 that in 2003 Blumenthal had spoken
at a rally supporting troops overseas.
The newspaper reported that Blumenthal
said when we returned,
we saw nothing like this.
That was a comparison with soldiers who
came back from Vietnam Blumenthal
repeatedly repeated a similar line in
2007 Memorial Day parade in Milford,
Connecticut,
and at a 2008 ceremony for veterans and
senior citizens.
Blumenthal said,
we have learned something
important since the days that I served
in Vietnam.
Ooh,
Yep.
And now look at the very bottom line.
Although I did not serve in Vietnam that
I've seen firsthand the effects of
military action.
Well,
that's cool story,
Bro.
He's a lot you think firsthand mean.
Yeah.
Well that's.
He said,
we have learned something important
since the days that I served in Vietnam.
If they quoted that and that's it.
He said that a 2008 ceremony,
that's a liar.
Yeah.
I mean,
that's just that stolen valor,
but you know,
it's,
it's a lie as much as it's still invalid
because he does have military service,
which,
you know,
I mean,
he was a part of the reserves,
which is an important part of the
military.
There's no,
I mean,
you don't want to diminish that,
but lying about having actually been in
Vietnam is,
it's as close to stolen valor you can
get with actually being a veteran.
Yeah,
yeah.
Right.
Yeah.
It's like shady shady,
but they're dirty people.
They're dirty people.
Yeah,
of course.
It's a dirty business.
It's a horrible,
horrible people.
So that's why when people are like,
venerating these monsters,
I'm like,
what the fuck is wrong with you?
These people are horrible.
Just doing that.
Just doing that alone.
Like that's what's hilarious that he got
through though.
Oh yeah.
It's,
it's funny when people can get away
with.
Does he ever said,
I'm sorry.
Shouldn't have said that.
What'd he say?
Oops,
I did it again.
Made mistakes and I have.
I have
spoken about my service and I regret
that and I take full responsibility.
You know,
full responsibility means resigning.
Does it?
If you're taking,
what does responsibility mean?
If there's no consequences?
Well,
that's a good question.
the consequences are public shaming.
Maybe he is the best person for the job,
despite the fact that he lied a decade
ago,
but I still didn't know what
responsibility means in this context.
I have taken responsibility.
I remember Janet,
I was a friend,
a mine.
Janet Reno.
When Waco happened in all those kids
died and all the sheep say Janet Reno
was a friend of yours.
A friend of mine was talking about
generally.
No,
no.
I knew Janet Reno Pals with Janet.
Reno was a friend of mine and she went
on TV after Waco and all those people
died and she goes,
this is my fault.
I take full responsibility.
My friends.
Like,
then you should be in jail if you are
responsible for murdering dozens of
people getting killed,
you should be in jail.
Know sasquatch.
Yeah.
How's that work?
Yeah,
just sturdy business.
It is a dirty business.
Is North Korea mad at us again?
I'm glad you're here today.
There was something this morning that I
was reading what happened this morning.
North Korea is angry at us again,
so they just cycles of North Korea,
so they'll do good cop,
bad cop.
And we saw this happen.
It was just really amazing.
So North Korea has this,
uh,
a weapon that causes everyone
on earth to have amnesia about the
career,
really angry.
So it was tensions as us,
tensions rise.
So they have this weapon that caused
everyone to have amnesia,
right?
So they'll do something and then people
forget what happened six months ago when
the Singapore summit was happening,
um,
and they were making nice and everyone's
just like,
oh blah blah.
I go,
last year they had sentenced president
trump to death.
They were threatening to new Guam and
everyone just completely forgot about
that.
And then like,
okay,
we're going to be nice.
It's like.
And then he cancels the summit,
the summit comes back on there,
they do this,
they've done this for years.
And it's like if you follow North Korea
as I do,
it's my gig.
You see it coming.
But then everyone's like,
oh my God,
they're mad at us.
This has never happened before.
Like this has happened for 70 years.
Motherfuckers.
This is their shtick.
So what do you think the purpose of it
is?
Just to stay relevant in the news and to
alert people that there's still conflict
between the two.
It's very important for them when they
make any sort of concessions to say that
they were putting up a fight.
We're not,
we're doing this because we want to,
not because you're making us doing it,
you know,
standing up for themselves.
We're not going to get pushed around
because they can't show submission or
weakness in any sense.
So president trump's been playing this
very intelligently and the rest then in
the corporate press won't tell you this
because it's everything's about trump.
I don't fucking care about trump and
this context.
I care what the North Korean people,
right?
The point is they are a,
they'll raise their radar rattler saber,
and then they'll be nice the next day
and then they rattled a saber there
nights.
Next Day it's,
it's,
it's as night follows day with them.
Well,
the culture is
a really fascinating culture.
The culture of Korea in general.
There's,
there's so much to it that we have a
really difficult time understanding.
Oh yes.
In terms of just the formalities in
which you're allowed to communicate with
people the in the way that they must
save face.
Right.
And what they're doing.
Anytime there's any sort of negotiation
there,
there has to be some sort of an
acknowledgement of their social status,
their position.
Yeah.
They're very.
And South Korea too,
so people think South Korea is like
America Junior.
It's not.
There are very different country from us
and just because they're our ally
doesn't mean they're all good guys too.
I was just reading Malcolm Gladwell's
outliers.
One of the things about it is how South
Korea dealt with.
They went through a crisis of plane
crashes and one of the problems with the
plane crashes was the way the
subordinates were not allowed to
question the pilots and the pilots
retired,
you know,
the way they fixed it,
they made them all speak English.
How would that fix it?
Because English is a different language
of the structure of the syntax
structure.
Sure.
Of politeness and deferment in in the
all the different things,
different sentences,
the way you're not allowed to
communicate with people in Korean where
there's a,
a,
a very strong tradition of like the
Malcolm Gladwell goes into in great
detail like superiors when they're
around their subordinates,
the subordinates are not allowed to
drink in front of them.
They can't smoke in front of them.
They have to turn away if they have a
drink in front of them,
like the way they talk to them,
they bow to them,
they call them sir and I went through
all this in taekwondo.
Taekwondo is very structured that way
and when I was teaching and when I was
a.
When I was working for my Korean
instructors,
like it was always sir,
it was always Mr Kim.
It was always very formal.
There was always bowing and it was,
there was,
you know,
and this is an Americanized version in
English with their language,
with the Korean language.
They were talking about all the
different proper forms of communication
and the structure that's in place to
establish who the dominant person is and
who the subordinate person
and in North Korea there's a tense that
they use only with regards to the
leaders.
So they've changed the language to that
extent.
Even for them.
Yeah.
So what they did was they made the South
Korean pilots,
like all of them,
English was the primary language of
communication.
They had to learn English now and they
had to learn on their own dime.
Oh there.
They'll learn English and then I think
they went with first names so we would
work together.
I wouldn't say Mr.
Malice like,
because then I would have.
I would be different.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I would say Mike,
we got some frost on the wing of this
plane.
We should probably defrost this fucker
and you and I would be.
Even though you would be the captain,
I would be your copilot.
We would still be able to talk to each
other as if we're friends and equals not
on this traditional Korean social story
structure
at this happened in America too.
Like people freak out that trump is
vulgar,
rising the presidency,
but it was a big deal of JFK and wear a
hat at his inauguration.
And even before that ambulance you
didn't have the hat.
It's like vulgar hats.
Imagine if it was important.
Imagine if trump wore a hat today.
I knew that hair.
I mean,
he's kind of wearing a hat.
Well,
he wears the make America great again
hat.
But I mean like a boulder hat,
like one of them.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Are there or the.
Yeah,
the wicker ones and,
and FDR gotten shit because he referred
to all his subordinates by their first
name and this was a huge deal back then.
Instead it's interest to Roosevelt.
They were.
Howard would be.
So he tried to be informal and correct
that he was being informed was like,
so this has been going on for a long
time.
The lack of formality.
Look how people used to dress in
airplanes.
They'd be been suits now there I had a
situation in a plane here.
These people are just like animals,
like dogs.
Dogs dress better than some of these
people.
Well,
they bring their dogs to bring in dogs
on planes and the subway in New York.
They started bringing them.
They always find your way.
All you have to do is have a piece of
paper from a doctor that says you need
help.
I don't think they needed a dog like on
the subway.
They just take them like,
what are you going to fucking do about
it?
Yet the bloods,
he goes,
let it go to shit.
That's a real problem with people that
are scared of dogs.
Allergic dogs.
What about you have two dogs.
They're going to get into a fight or
they start shitting somewhere.
We know we're not.
We don't want to San Francisco.
We don't have shit on the streets.
That's true.
Yeah.
Wow.
What happened?
What do you mean with Blasio?
Like what's he doing?
He's just basically like,
dude,
what the fuck you want?
I'm not going to enforce Giuliani's like
quality of life rules.
So the new thing that the credence of
started doing,
this happens at the gym and this happens
I seen on subway they just start playing
their music.
What do you mean people have their head,
they're little,
uh,
iphone.
They just start playing music.
No headphones and I'm just like,
wow,
you need police brutality because
obviously if you're this removed from
what's appropriate behavior talk is not
going to do for you.
Well,
if the gym doesn't the gym have its own
music.
Yeah,
it does.
People play their music over the gym and
the locker room and some fucking dudes
just playing his music.
I'm like,
what the fuck are you doing?
Oh,
and the pattern,
the weight,
yet I don't my point.
I'm the small dude,
you know,
I can't go over to these beasts at the
gym and be like,
excuse me sir,
your music's disturbing.
Like workout.
What kind of music you're dealing with?
Is it rap?
I,
I almost always know.
And that's like,
it's like the gym,
you're going to have like heavy metal or
rap or heavy metal,
right?
Dark,
dark,
that kind of shit.
Trying to put your underwear on and
you're thinking of peaceful thoughts
after a nice workout or I'm trying to
drop some sick burns on twitter and I'm
like,
guys,
I've got some good verbiage.
Chair dropping sick burns guys.
Excuse me sir.
Could you please cut down that mumble
rap?
I'm dropping.
Excuse me over here.
He's me,
sir.
I'm dunking on Tucker Carlson.
You're dunking on him.
The poor guy.
He gets a free pass.
What's matter of Jimmy?
I'd never heard that.
Kennedy and things,
so I looked it up.
He actually,
according to snopes,
revived an inaugural hat wearing
tradition.
He did wait.
Kennedy did not wear that.
He walked all the way without his hat.
That's not what this says.
This is from 2007 on snopes.
He was wearing it most of the day.
This is like a long like,
oh yeah,
look,
he's wearing it.
It's like a rumor that he killed the
hat.
Industry will scroll.
Scroll down.
You can see him wearing it.
Yeah,
he's wearing a most of the day there.
As he gave his speech,
he took it off,
put it back on for the rest of the day.
Interested in is like a long room and
it's been going on.
That's interesting.
We'll get that fella.
Should've had it lined with lead,
Huh?
Well,
I don't think that would have helped.
It wouldn't hurt.
It wouldn't help the shot to the neck.
He took a look at that.
Uh,
that hat with him with the hat.
Look at that.
It's also weird seeing him like a
talking truman.
Like there's some such different areas.
I know,
right.
You would think that they weren't alive
together.
Well,
Herbert Hoover,
he visited at the White House.
Herbert Hoover visited JFK.
Wow.
I look at,
look at Lyndon Johnson thinking three
more years,
man.
And I'm going to be president.
I'm going to get you shot and it gets.
You fucker look at him looking over at
him and your brother too.
Maybe I'll fuck your wife when you're
dead.
Lyndon Johnson used to take shifts with
the press right in front of them.
Yeah.
Let them in the bathroom was dropping
logs.
Yeah.
And he would like whip out his dick all
the time.
He was like,
the hell horrible person.
Horrible for us because he whipped his
dick out.
Doesn't make them a horrible person.
No,
that'd be really happy with his Dick.
Well,
that's true.
That's not.
Does not make him a horrible person.
The horrible person is the guys whipping
out his dick and playing his music at
black room.
That's the horrible.
That's a horrible person.
If he's playing that led music and he's
stroking his cock at the same time,
that's a horrible precedent.
I guess there's a locker room and you're
just trying to drop sick burns.
I'm trying to.
Yeah,
jail.
It's all I want to do.
I just did my dead lifts pathetically.
Are you gonna?
Leave.
See Tucker Carlson alone for a little
while.
I never took it on as I.
I've been on Tucker's show a few times.
I've never gotten tucker face,
so I'm very,
very happy face.
Oh,
when he gives you that look.
Yeah.
I've never gotten.
Who's going after you?
He's never done that.
So he's been very respectful because
very few people know North Korea.
That's what I'm there to talk about,
so they're not.
I'm not being coming at that from a
partisan perspective at all.
Right.
You're coming to educate.
So I've never gotten heat about that at
all.
I wonder what's going to happen with
them and all this stuff because now that
his house is a bit like people know
where his house is,
when you probably going to move,
as you know,
when you don't have to.
Someone's family that sets off some part
of your brain that's something fierce
and he's not gonna just take this lying
down.
Yeah,
I mean I wonder if there's legal action
it's going to be had.
I don't know.
It's all fucked up man.
It's just we've it,
we've never had a time where in my life
where I can remember the left and the
right being so combative,
not just disagreeing about things,
not just a debating things,
but this kind of shit.
Like riots,
like you know,
this is of the right was on their knees
all this time for a long time and now
they're like,
you know what,
you people are fucking terrible.
Fuck you.
Is that the case,
man?
There's never.
Is it the right was underneath.
There was never a left wing anti foot
type organization because the right was
being subordinate to them in many ways,
like the press had a complete monopoly
on speech.
Twenty 12,
2012.
Mitt Romney's having this debate with
Obama,
Candy Crowley.
He's the moderator,
right?
The moderator,
and she starts arguing with Mitt Romney
during the debate.
You're the fucking moderator.
Sit down and shut up late.
You're arguing about.
She's like,
Oh,
you got this tax wrong,
blah,
blah.
And she,
even before the debate,
she says,
I'm going to correct them if necessary.
Bitch,
you're the moderator.
Sit down.
Shut the fuck up.
She's supposed to.
If she knows something's,
she's not supposed to say anything.
It's like a judge.
If the judge has two sides as someone's
deloitte is lying,
it's the other lawyer has to make it up.
That's a good point.
But as a moderator,
aren't you also some kind of an immune.
You not necessarily an entertainer,
but you're,
you're moving the thing along.
If you know something to be incorrect.
Like if someone says,
uh,
you know,
I am James Brown,
Shot Jfk,
I am sure that there was a contract that
the Romney team and the Obama team sat
down and worked out between them.
Like how much time?
The forum,
the location.
I'm sure that said the moderate.
We're going to find an honest objective.
Moderate who is not gonna interfere.
There's no fucking way they wouldn't.
Mm.
Was she correct?
No,
I don't think she was.
He look it up.
I'm 99 percent sure she was wrong too.
That's hilarious.
And he,
but he,
it,
he just ate it.
He just ate.
And then you have then in 2016 where
they're just telling the fucking report
is,
fuck you.
You're not the holly talk.
Ted Cruz lost to shit on them.
He's like,
what kind of questions are these,
you know,
and the audience.
Cheers.
Not.
That was a big turning point it.
So here it is.
Yeah.
Did the attack.
He went in the Rose Garden and said that
this was an act of terror.
You said in the Rose Garden the day
after the attack.
It was an act of terror.
It was not a spontaneous demonstration,
is that what you're saying?
Please proceed.
Gunner,
I want to make sure we get that for the
record because it took the president 14
days before he called the attack in
Benghazi,
an act of terror.
Get the transfer.
He didn't.
In fact,
sir.
So let me,
let me call it an activity that he did
call her an act of terror.
It did as well.
Take it.
Did as well.
Uh,
take a two weeks or so.
for the whole idea of there being a riot
out there about this tape to come out.
You're okay.
Right?
The administration,
the administration indicated that this
was a,
a reaction.
Do I do a video and was a spontaneous
reaction.
It took them a long time to say this was
a terrorist act by a terrorist group
and,
and to suggest it or am I incorrect in
that regard?
On,
on Sunday,
the,
uh,
your,
your secretary,
or excuse me,
the ambassador to the United Nations one
of the Sunday to television shows and,
and spoke about how this was a
spontaneous.
I'm happy to have a longer conversation
about for policy,
but I want.
I want to move you one and all.
Hm.
What'd she seemed like?
She was just agreeing and seemed like
she was still on her role.
Right.
It's still a hurdle.
Say you're wrong about this.
You write about this in my opinion.
But anyway,
that's.
I don't think she said you're wrong
though.
Did she?
She said that is correct.
It took two weeks.
I mean she's basically with Ron.
Was there another example of this?
Because I remember that I remember it
got heated between the two of them so I
could be talking to my ass,
but I could see.
Use your.
You being correct that even what she did
there in saying that he's correct is
really out of line,
right?
Yeah.
She seemed a little flustered.
They're like not exactly sure what to do
and what not to do,
but there have been many example people
forgot about that.
Ben Gazi thing was
the same one.
I don't know if this was the same one.
There's no volume.
I don't know why just died.
Okay.
Either way.
Yeah.
It seems like she's doing the same
thing,
but that Ben Gazi thing that was.
That was so bizarre.
People forgot about how that they were
trying to blame it on that video.
Your movie or video?
What was it called?
Something I don't remember,
and Hillary,
I think at the time when she was
secretary of state,
she refused to go on and they made Susan
rice walk the plank for that one.
Oh,
that was a weird one,
man.
That movie was weird.
It was so bad.
It was almost like a.
Did they blame it on loose change?
Is that the one that they play?
No,
no,
no.
It
was a movie.
It was like a terrible movie that
someone had made like the tiers of the
Muslims or something like that.
I forget the name of it,
but it was so bad.
It almost seemed like a parody film or
some people had said like,
this is like,
this is some CIA production.
It's interesting how memory works.
I remembered it being much more
combative than it was when we just
watched it and I would have sworn on a
bible that it was very,
very heated and then looking at that,
it wasn't that bad.
Well,
this brings us back to what we're
talking about with cabinet and thinking
about things that happen when you're 17.
Right?
And tribalism.
Yeah.
I mean the memory that we have sucks.
It's just shitty.
It's just being a human being.
I mean I have some absolute memories
about facts that I know to be true in
terms of like statistics and things that
took place and that I've stored in my
memory because of my job because like,
especially when it comes to fights,
like I have a pretty good database of
fight.
We'd even then occasionally I'm like,
is that how it went?
Why don't I think it was the second
round,
Huh?
Yeah.
Memory suck.
Yeah,
it does.
Yeah.
Especially when you're drinking booze
will be telling me about all that booze
you drink.
Oh God,
what are you doing?
This is such a good.
Oh,
the arduous march.
Yeah.
Okay.
This is really exciting.
So I went on this rabbit hole,
I'm not a big drinker,
right?
And I did this.
I have a lot.
I did a live stream and I tried eight
different kinds of Heinz Ketchup because
I love Heinz Ketchup and I thought this
is a different kinds.
I'm like,
yeah,
let's.
I'm like,
let's work out.
I'm going to try all eight and give my
opinion in all eight.
And I said,
I went down a rabbit hole and I thought
with all this weird liquor,
I'm not a big drinker if you guys want
to pay for these bottles,
the stupid,
the live stream people,
the audience,
I'll buy them and I'll,
I'll do it.
And they just kept checking in.
I bought 32 bottles November 16th.
Me and six of my buddies are going to
be.
And I'm like,
how do I return value guys are chipping
in for these bottles.
They go do it with people.
So it's me and six of my friends were
doing quarter shots and seeing if we get
through all 32 of these weird liquors,
uh,
and you can quit at any shots.
Well,
32 times a quarter to eight shots.
I know,
that's what I'm saying.
That's a lot.
That's a lot of booze.
It's a lot of booze and some of them are
really exciting somewhere.
And not succeeding mouth.
It's going to be numb after like shot
number five and also the different
alcohol by proof.
They're different.
Every one's a different flavor.
They're all crazy.
Um,
so I,
I,
it's just,
I'm very,
very excited with this.
We're going to be streaming it from
compound and at my house.
Yeah.
I found there's this one company from.
This is for credit for people.
If people want to have credit,
there's this company from Denmark,
you probably haven't heard them called
empirical spirits.
So this guy's really wanker.
This former chef,
and he figured out new ways to make
liquor and he made one that's Habanero,
but the capsaicin doesn't get through
the distilling process.
So I can't handle heat.
I'm a bitch.
You're drinking the tastes that Habanero
is without any of the heat.
Wow.
And then he made
one which tastes called Charlene Mcgee.
It's the character from firestarter,
Drew Barrymore's character.
It's like drinking smoke.
But it's smooth,
so it's really cool.
What's the Habanero one calls A.
I hate the name because it's so
pedestrian because it's so creative.
What he's done and it's called fuck
trump and his stupid fucking will.
No.
Yeah,
no.
the wait a minute.
He's got five of them.
The whiskey is whiskey or bourbon,
like I don't know what to call it
because it's a new kind of a gala core.
I think it for tech.
I don't know what the term is because
they're distilling it into crazy siphiwe
and it's called fuck trump and his
stupid fucking wall.
Yeah.
That's literally the name of it.
Look.
Yeah.
That's hilarious.
It sounds delicious.
It is.
The idea of.
I'm really excited about the idea of
Habanero without the heat.
Although I do like heat.
There isn't say unfortunately we can not
see.
This is so crazy that that is the actual
name of the booze and he's got one which
is of.
What's that monetary?
What does that.
KKR Denmark.
Chronic muggers.
Dinner Crowns.
Yeah.
He's got one which is called a soup
blend,
which is Russell Minute,
which is spices mixed with a cocoa
shells.
Jamie,
order us a bottle of this jazz.
You can get it for you.
What's it say?
You can't get it to the states.
So here's the thing,
Joe.
There's like two.
There's two stores in America that have
it.
I have it.
I'll get you a bottle.
Told ones in Brooklyn.
This one's in Manhattan.
I don't know where the other one is.
It's really fun.
That is.
He's making one now out of tuna.
Tuna fish.
Now think how smart you have to be to
turn tune into a drinkable liquor.
I was on Anthony Show and one of his
boys brought in some beer that's made
with weed.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
The scientist guy.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Drank.
Some of that was a horrible,
very good.
They all listened to his bat and it will
fuck you up.
It was 100 milligrams in the whole
bottle and I drank about a third of the
bottle and I was like,
yikes.
I feel that.
Here we go.
I was high for a couple of hours after
that.
Shit.
That shit.
That's just no joke.
No joke.
Eddy edibles are no joke,
man.
And that was for me,
that was post sober October so that we
drink was the first marijuana I had had
a whole month.
So it kiss your ass.
It was pretty good.
I'm scared of this,
uh,
argyris.
I'm not going to lie.
You shouldn't be scared.
All that stuff.
Fuck trump and the stupid fucking wall.
You should be scared of that.
Well,
that's sweet.
Is it?
Yeah.
That one I tried.
Was it,
can you compare it to something?
Um,
because he cuts it with Habanero vinegar
also,
isn't there?
So it's got a vinegar kick it.
See,
the thing is when you're Willy Wonka,
nothing's like it.
Right?
So like,
it's hard for me to have the vocabulary
to compare these two.
It's got the bell pepper kind of
sweetness.
Wow.
It doesn't have a burn.
So it's,
it's smooth.
Um,
the fire that charlene is the one I
really liked.
The fire one.
It's so crazy.
It feels like a dragon.
What's the alcohol
content in something like this is
Charlene Makia thinks 40,
80 proof.
This one's I think 54 proof.
So it's pretty strong.
Yeah.
Let's go kick.
It's got a kick goals.
Something going on there.
50 proof means 25 percent alcohol,
right?
Yeah.
Man.
These wizards today,
they're doing all kinds of things.
That's what drives me crazy when people
are like,
there's nothing interesting out there.
There's your fan of this.
There's so many creative people in every
field.
Nothing interesting out there.
Basic people.
Non-Content monkey sees it.
There's a lot of basic bitches.
I'm like,
dude,
there's so much.
So what does an NPC.
You don't know this meme.
Is that a scientology thing?
No.
Non-Player character.
Non-Player can't.
You don't know about this.
Do I get to tell you the MPC means this
is the most important to you for a
lifetime?
Yeah.
Okay.
Here we go.
Breaking it down as quickly as possible.
I'm going to show my age.
When you.
When we were younger,
we played games like final fantasy and
ultimate.
Right,
and in those games you go to like the
armor store or the weapons store and
you're by your sword or you buy your
armor.
There's a guy running that store within
the game.
Yes.
He does not exist outside of that store.
Right.
That character,
all he does is by armor and sell armor.
He doesn't have a life.
It doesn't a kid.
You go there at midnight,
he's there.
You go there at 8:00
AM,
he's there,
he's the player characters you're
playing.
He's the non-player character and the
point this mean makes is the vast
majority of humans are non player
characters.
They have no pr mind outside their
programming,
so they call it msnbc or the at NPC is
the network and you'll go look the press
corps,
there'll be like orange man,
bad in peach,
45 Russia,
and that's all they know how to say,
and you see this on twitter where it's
one thing when people say cliched ideas,
but they'll say cliched ideas in a
cliched way.
Yeah,
and it's like you have no mind.
You're just repeating what has been
programmed to you and your script and as
soon as you mentioned certain terms,
is it just a kneejerk speech that they
give and once you identify identified,
it's like the Matrix,
like you see agent Smith everywhere.
Yeah.
There's also a weird laziness to that.
Yes.
The,
the,
the.
There's some people that know that
that's what that is and they accept it
and they just do it anyway.
Right.
And then because they know they can get
away with it.
Yes.
Yeah,
I see that in journalism too.
Well,
I mean the White House,
I mean journalism are,
they had a pullup maddow npc because
there's a picture hurts that's tonight
on MSNBC,
orange man.
Bad or like the angry intellectual show,
I think they call her.
It's,
it's hilarious.
And the twitter freak the fuck out and
started banning a lot of these accounts
because this is really a calling the
bluff and a lot of these people like
these twitter banned because they say
it's dehumanizing.
Well,
they didn't give a reason,
but that's the ostensible reason,
theoretically sooner never explained.
It's dehumanizing to call someone a non
player characters in effect.
In a way.
If you're saying they have no mind or
soul,
but is it okay to scrawl them a basic
bitch?
Yes.
Apparently it's super similar.
What about calling someone a fucking
Nazi?
Right.
Why was that so easy?
Because when you're calling someone
Nazi,
you are reading them effectively out of
human race.
You're saying this person
is not deserving of any semblance of
decency of fairness,
and that's not a crazy perspective.
They see ultimate subhuman designation.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
It's the new n word,
right?
Yeah.
Not seeing it is,
but it's.
It's.
It's actually really easy to say you
can't.
You can't pull it up.
Not the actual thing that you asked for,
but memes of her as this.
Yeah.
That's the one.
The third one.
That one.
That right there.
Oh,
well,
the outrage intellectual show.
What's really hilarious is listening to
the liberals go off on her like real
progressives,
like Jimmy Dore,
great.
Jimmy Dore,
Michael Tracy,
Glenn Greenwald.
None of them follow me.
They wish they would,
but they're there.
I hate when the right things.
Everyone.
The left's the same,
there are many people on the left who
are not pc,
who are brilliant,
who have left wing ideas and convictions
and they call shit out,
but the percentage of them in comparison
to the percentage that just follow the
narrative is so small that we were just
talking about earlier,
90 slash 10,
90 percent of any population are going
to be npcs and 10 percent are going to
be the innovators.
Yeah.
Jimmy Dore goes off on her when I'm
doing the arduous march.
Me and the six friends.
It's Jay Irwin who was a four.
Chan Maude,
my Buddy Michael Wolf,
strength coach Matt,
who was an immigrant and that's a
Virginia Simon's an immigrant.
My friend Paul,
I didn't have a name for him,
so I said,
you're going to be Paul and Dave Smith.
We know he's gonna.
Be excited from the Romney win,
and I said,
Paul,
I'm just going to say Paul the NPC,
and he immediately went out and got a
gray sweatshirt and gray a ski to where
it's.
It just looked like the name sounds very
proud of Paul.
What?
What Romney.
When I'm not aware,
Ronnie's the senator from Utah.
He just was.
He just got elected Tuesday.
How does he go from Massachusetts to
Utah?
He's got,
he's a mormon.
He's got the matching underwear.
But did he move there?
Did he have to move there to get that?
Utah does think he lived there before
Massachusetts because he ran the
Olympics,
didn't he?
Out of Salt Lake.
I'm sure he's got.
If you're a Mormon,
you've got Utah Roots.
Yeah.
He's so reasonable in comparison to
trump.
Oh,
I don't know if people would vote for
him now.
I think he's going to know.
I think he's completely soulless and I
don't think people look away.
I don't think people go for
reasonability.
Uh,
he was four.
He,
he attack.
He went to the left of Ted Kennedy for
gay marriage and he's against it.
He's saying Romneycare works for
Massachusetts,
but it won't work for America.
What the fuck does that mean?
Wait a minute.
He was the,
to the left of Ted Kennedy when it came
to gay marriage.
Look up a romney.
Ted Kennedy gay rights.
He asked me.
He was for gay rights.
Then he's against it.
Pro choice pro life.
What was his reasoning for going against
it?
Because now he's running for the
Republican presidents.
The guy's a fucking phony.
He's an odd duck.
That's for sure.
But could you not be your dad's Mexican?
His Dad is Mexican.
Yeah,
that's true.
His Dad is like born in Mexico.
You know what happened with his dad?
He was governor of Michigan and he was
going to probably be the Republican
nominee and 68 or 72.
And then he said he got brainwashed
would.
Yeah.
And then it was like,
what the fuck does that mean?
Romney,
I'll be better than Ted for gay.
Nineteen 94.
Yep.
So what happened?
His Dad got brainwashed that said he was
brainwashed.
I don't remember.
I don't remember the press somebody.
And they're like,
are you saying you're crazy?
Yeah.
This was the thing.
So that did a in that did him in.
Yeah.
You can't say you got brainwashed.
No.
You got to be saying,
you got to be saying I'm impervious.
Yes.
Brainwashed me,
motherfucker.
He could look 25 percent tariff.
Yeah,
that's hilarious.
That's a great way.
Hey,
I got brainwashed.
It's a great way to exonerate yourself.
It isn't though.
It's like,
you know what?
I talked about this in my next book.
I'm when people on the left are saying
trump is gaslighting me.
If your gas lit,
that means you're crazy.
Gas Lit means someone is making you feel
insane.
That's the definition of that.
Yeah.
I don't think they understand that.
No,
that's a weird term.
Gasoline.
I don't know.
I think I've ever used it.
I've only read it.
It's been a movie.
What movie?
Gaslight.
Oh,
you didn't know where the term comes
from.
There's a movie from the forties where
the husband is trying to convince the
wife.
She's going insane.
So he's like changing the light bulbs
and like fucking with her head.
So two gas lights.
When you manipulate someone to believe
they're going crazy.
So how can someone say that trump has
manipulating them into believing they're
going crazy.
They think.
Do they think that he's making them
crazy because he's just such an asshole
that he's making them crazy?
Is that what you're saying?
He's such a liar that he's making me
lose my sense of reality,
but,
but the person who's the recipient of
gaslighting is not in a good place no
matter how you cut it.
Right.
You're either losing touch with reality.
You're doubting things,
you're losing your mind.
You don't want to be that guy or that
girl.
Don't give gifts.
Yeah.
Don't get gas lit and they'll say,
you're getting gas lit.
That's the movie from the twenties,
thirties,
forties.
I need to go see that.
It's a brilliant idea.
Yeah,
it sounds like it.
it sounds funny.
It is hilarious.
It's funny to watch it too,
like the time period.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I think it's Ingmar Bergman.
Yeah.
This is a major,
major film.
Oh,
what a creative plot.
Yeah,
that is.
That's very creative.
You know what's the most creative show?
I think one of the most creative and
innovative shows of all time is the
twilight zone.
If you think about all the different
premises they covered in the twilight
zone.
I'm like,
good Lord.
What a bounty of creative ideas.
Right?
And every one of those was like.
It was like a twist and it has one every
three years.
They got to do it every week.
He nailed it with one.
He nailed it with the sixth sense and
then after that it was like,
like the,
the village with all like living in a
place.
Planes aren't allowed to fly over there.
Yeah,
right,
right.
You find out they're right next to a
road.
You can walk to a road and a day,
like what?
You know how long that that's 20 miles
man.
It's not that far.
Like you're 20 miles from people and
you're telling me people never got to
your village.
Did you guessed the ending for the
success?
I guess it right away.
No,
I didn't.
Okay.
I missed it.
I think when you're being like,
I dunno,
I was just
coming in and like.
And I guess the usual suspects also.
Did you?
Yeah,
because all those movies,
when you come in looking at it from a
writer perspective,
it's like,
okay,
they have to show their hand in the
first two minutes because then you can
be like,
oh,
it's been an ally the whole time.
So I'm like watching him like that.
I didn't see the one where the plants
come alive and killed people.
I'm sure it's retarded.
I'm just saying it's bad.
It's really mark Wahlberg,
right?
Yes.
What was implanted here?
Who was.
Who was in planet of the apes.
Oh,
was he?
Yeah.
Was He?
Yes,
he was.
Well,
why don't you remember.
Do you think a child has to know the,
the,
the guy who played the doctor.
James Franco.
He played the dog.
Oh,
that's right.
Wasn't it?
I don't know.
I never saw it.
I know mark Wahlberg's delete and
killing a baton.
Carter,
I believe.
Yeah.
Isn't she the,
the James Franco was the one who was
trying to.
He trained the chimp and that's when the
chimp went crazy and he was helping the
chimp.
This was going to be the first episode
of Joe Rogan with that chip mentions in.
Here we go.
Too late.
Yeah.
Look at that.
It's Mucky muck.
We years this.
Oh,
it's the other one.
First one.
The first and the.
When they brought it back.
Really pretty sure.
Yeah,
there it is.
Wow.
Look at the image,
the 2001 right above that,
the one to the right of that.
Like that.
I to look at that.
And that's good makeup.
Fuck yeah,
it is probably a little bit of CGI,
right?
It's still impressive.
No,
it's totally amazing.
That's crazy that that was 2001.
That's right.
So there's that.
I feel like this was a totally different
one than the one that was from 2010.
Like almost like it was a reboot,
like I don't think they were the same
probably.
I think that.
I think that's true.
I don't think that it's the universe.
Yeah,
I think it's just totally different
thing.
Wasn't this Tim Burton?
It was Tim Burton.
Yeah.
So in this one,
marky mark comes to the future and finds
the plant of the apes and the whole
deal.
But in the next one,
the next reboot,
which was the James Franco one,
James Franco is a part of the actual
medical experiments at turn.
Caesar's,
like a prequel.
Yeah,
that's what it was.
There's been a lot of planet of the apes
movies.
People are Goddamn.
Except there we are,
we are like really obsessed with
chimpanzees.
I can't wait for the crossover with the
Muslim Brotherhood movie.
I don't think they're going to do that.
I'm going to call it.
Call it barrel aged.
Valerie Jarrett,
I think once they canceled the connors
that went out,
they got into vine in development.
Hell 10 years in between.
Yeah,
that's what it is.
The.
So the,
the one that took place on 2011.
Look at that of them.
Okay.
Yeah.
Then that one was the one where they
explained the rise of the planet.
Yeah.
They give them the injection and the
chimp gets super smart and their changed
color.
There's little member's eyes turned
blue,
which is racist.
Racist.
You have to be blue eyed by smart.
Fuck.
Thank you.
It's appreciate it means something to
them.
Right?
Um,
what were we talking about when we got
to plant of the apes?
Like what?
Sean Shama Lama Ding Dong.
He had a few of the highlights on.
You were talking about,
you know,
what one movie that he had that's good
though,
that people don't talk about is devil.
That's when the elevator,
right?
Yeah,
definitely worth watching.
I haven't seen it.
I enjoyed that.
That's one of my facebook banner picks.
It's me in front of the movie poster for
Devil.
Yeah.
Okay.
That was not bad.
Yeah.
If you're.
If you're looking for a dumb horror
movie,
it's like fun though.
There was bad.
I actually,
Chrissy Tiegen,
I don't know who she is,
but she's famous.
She's got a lot of twitter.
One of those ones that I couldn't
recognize her.
I couldn't pick her out of a lineup and
she's famous and this isn't a knock on
her.
I just saying personally,
I don't know who she is,
but she's out of the loop.
She tweeted out that,
you know,
after thinking all this time,
I'm going to vote for the Democrats and
I just retweeted.
I go,
yeah.
Directly by that channel.
There's a twist ending Hollywood lady
votes for Democrats.
After thinking all this time,
I've been thinking for a 14 minute.
What does that mean?
Everything thinking all this time I've
watched a few can.
Oh,
and speeches and I'm not totally.
I'm just not sold.
Did you know Konya?
Had some good points,
but I don't know.
Did you see the Qantas Owens and Tomi
Lahren?
We're getting into it on twitter today
now.
Like two weeks ago.
I missed it.
It was this big cat fight.
Really?
Yeah,
it was hilarious.
Would they say like,
Tommy's was subtweeting her.
She wouldn't use her name.
She goes,
Oh,
you know,
bla bla bla bla bla.
And candice is like,
Tommy Comma,
like,
you're jealous because your career is a
disaster,
blah,
blah.
Yeah,
it was,
it was beef,
but at the,
on the same extensively turned on.
Candice throw her under the bus.
Oh yeah.
Oh,
Kanye turned on candice.
Oh yeah.
He says I'm not involved in.
I'm not involved in politics anymore.
Right,
but how's that turning on canvas?
Because she could.
She just heard the name and the tweets.
What he say.
He said,
candice,
whatever.
I'll find the tweet if you want.
But so she was,
I don't want to speak for her,
but she launched this whole brexit thing
and basically implied that he was
involved and he's like,
I'm not.
I've been used by people in politics and
not doing it well.
Look at her.
She.
She wasn't a hard.
Oh yeah,
they both to turn on Kanye.
Now the ship was doomed to sync from the
start,
but hunger for fame and money was placed
over the movement.
Funny how he was a free thinker in
quotes before and now he's a trader and
quotes sounds a lot like a tactic of the
left.
I liked how she capitalized left.
Yeah.
You made your bed now lie in it.
I think he was laying.
Laying,
right?
Yeah.
Well maybe not.
Maybe it's a double entendre or maybe
maybe it'd be in factual.
Tommy.
I think I can speak on behalf of people
on both sides of the political aisle and
say we're sorry about your failed
career.
That this is hilarious.
She's saying this.
She's literally had a career in this for
about eight months and you're failed
career.
You know,
she used to run an anti-trump website.
A excite you mean?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
The desperation to be relevant again by
constantly saving me and slash or
attacking Kathy Griffin weekly.
Make sure it doesn't bode well for any
movement.
Grow Up.
Whenever anyone writes,
grow up.
I always hear it in cartons voice.
Is that it?
Did they go out into the further?
Always was just one little bit of back
and forth.
Yeah.
That's so silly.
Oh,
Owen's went on the defensive Wednesday
after West rejected claims that he
designed or created by Lexit tee shirts.
What is black,
black,
black lives they could show to called a
black set?
Yeah.
Like they mean the blacks leaving the
Democratic Party.
And why didn't they do that?
I don't.
You'd have to ask candice and our Kanye
and our.
Kathy Griffin.
Yeah.
Well I get they did it because of
brexit.
Yeah,
but black.
It's center.
Yeah.
Below.
That's not bad.
Black exit.
Yeah,
but black state is also black exit.
Yeah.
It's called blaxploitation movies.
Right.
But exit is spelled e x I t and if you
just have bel and then fix it,
it's actually better.
I,
if you want to be sure precisely
spelling is better,
but in terms of how,
how it said,
I think blacks,
it sounds lacks it.
I have to opposite.
I don't think either.
You don't have to create exit,
you just keep exiting there and just be
all the beginning of it and it works or
it flex.
It also works.
Let's.
I've sure candace think you're married
to your idea of blacks.
It's needed to let it go.
You're a writer.
You know how to kill your babies.
I don't have any black vaping's.
No excavating writing.
You kill your darlings.
Kill your darling.
Kill your shitty ideas.
Yeah,
blacks.
It's a shitty idea.
Black sit is where it's at.
Is it?
Yeah.
Brexit.
They were right.
Do you think that this is gonna be a lot
of people,
black people leaving the Democratic
Party?
I don't think so.
Yeah.
No,
I think there's going to be a few that
recognize that it's a genuine pathway to
attention and I think there's going to
be.
A lot of people are going to sit home.
Yeah.
That's what African American.
There's a few.
Listen,
there's a few on both sides of the aisle
that are contrarians,
hucksters,
you know,
there's just two different types of
posts.
The contrarians are people that don't
like the fact that they are being told
that as an African American I have to
vote Democrat and I have to lean left
and they're like,
fuck this,
you know,
you don't tell me what to do.
And then they go that way.
I think we're getting a little bit of
that from Kanye West and then there's
people that recognize that there is,
there's legitimate pathway to start them
to attention to,
you know,
it's just a,
it's a career in being like reciting
conservative talking points as an
African American.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
I mean it's an affirmative action.
But it's um,
and especially,
you know,
if you can get a little juice on some
sort of argument with some Tommy Lauren
check or any of these.
I was confused.
Her and Lauren Southern,
they're very different.
I know,
but they're both hot.
They're both hot plates on.
That's all I say.
I'm not really paying attention to what
they're saying.
Well,
I don't think that's fair to Lauren.
How dare you.
What do you mean had there has,
is lauren the superior to the title?
I'm not going to,
I mean,
if I wouldn't have said not fair to
Lauren,
so lauren is better than Tommy.
Uh,
I think Lauren,
Tommy is very much someone who's there
to have a,
a standard Republican point of view.
What she does well and is that lauren is
more of kind of a filmmaker and she's
much edgier.
I mean,
she's,
she went with Molyneux to Australia.
There was all this beef beef about going
Australia,
like they wanted to stop their talks.
Uh,
she's done.
She's going to South Africa to do work.
They want to stop that.
Everybody's talks,
they want to stop Tommy's talks to.
They want to start stock of lawrence
onto more controversial and more
controversial.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
She's very anti anti immigrant.
She went to Europe to see the migrant
camps.
Um,
so you're not going to see Lauren really
on these mainstream outlets.
Um,
well I know Lauren was referenced in a
lot of the discussions that I was having
with people on twitter about people in
South Africa who are farmers getting
murdered.
Right.
She had a documentary called farmlands.
Yeah.
That was a weird one where people were
getting angry at me and saying that I
was reciting a racist conspiracy theory.
I'm like,
okay,
but this is a racist conspiracy theory
that a black person was talking about in
front of Congress.
I mean,
this is a black African guy talking
about it on television in Africa,
the problems with farm murders,
you know,
and then there was that guy who was the
one who wants reparations,
who was in South Africa,
who's a very controversial character,
who was.
He was kicked out of one of their
organizations for doing a song singing
about killed the board.
Yes,
he's doing it and making guns sounds and
the audience is cheering around along
with his song with gun sounds,
and it's about killing farmers.
The term conspiracy theory is a tactic
that the press and people use to shut
down conversation.
If you think about it,
Harvey Weinstein was a conspiracy
theory.
Bill cosby was a conspiracy theory.
Kevin Spacey was a conspiracy theory.
Everyone knew everyone and everyone kept
their mouth shut.
Yeah,
so the idea that a conspiracy theories
inherently false is itself inherently
false and it's just a way to stigmatize
a school of thought or an idea that you
don't want to talk about.
Well,
it's also labeling it as a racist
ideologies.
That's true too.
Yeah.
You,
you are immediately
rate and they also.
It was because of trump reciting it.
Trump had repeated it on television
talking about something in terms of the
issue with South African farmers.
It's,
but it's one of those things that we
were talking about before where even if
they know that the narrative is not
true,
it supports what they're trying to push
so they run with it and so I just kept
doubling down.
I kept posting all these different
things about it.
I was like,
well,
what about this guy talking about it?
What about this?
What about here's,
here's some instances of these murders,
and then there's also the reality of
South Africa in general,
which is extremely violent.
There's a lot of violence and there's a
lot of crime and some of it has to do
with the fact that these people that are
in these farms are targets because
they're out in the middle of nowhere and
whether or not it's racist that they're
going after them because they're white.
That's debatable,
but black farmers are also getting
attacked.
It's not simply just white farmers.
There is some of that though,
but there's some of that.
Some of them are going after these
farmers because they're white and this.
The thing that's really disturbing is
are people that people are happier if
this is black people killing other black
people like the Hutu and the Tutsis.
That was the genocide and so yeah,
it's a problem when people are being
killed regardless of their race and
tribalism cuts across racial lines,
but on the other side there was also
some,
some legitimate claims to land that was
stolen,
stolen during apartheid,
and that the people who are alive today
who might not have been around during
the stealing of that land,
are benefiting from the fact that
they're.
They're living on stolen land.
Like that's all legitimate as well.
So there's legitimate arguments in terms
of like how the land was procured in the
first place and how the person who's
owning it today,
how they came to own it.
So there's,
it's,
it's complex,
it's very complex,
but it also has to do with this culture
of violence in Africa in general,
especially particularly in South Africa
where there's a lot of poverty and you
know,
these people who are out in these farms
in the middle of their targets,
people don't what politics from both
sides who wants to teach us is that
policy things that never complex,
right?
So if you have your little package and
some things doesn't fit in that package,
you don't know what to make of it.
So you want to dismiss it because then
you're going to have to do the work of
reconsidering your,
uh,
assumptions and certainly don't discuss
it publicly where you could be
misconstrued or labeled as a racist.
And I was looking at all these people
labeling me as a racist.
I was like,
okay,
I see what you're doing,
but I'm just going to keep posting these
things because this is all what I'm
saying is all being substantiated by a
bunch of different people were also
black in South Africa like this.
This is a lot of what this discussion
revolves around.
What trump's done is had had that word
lose a lot of its meaning because like
if you just throw that term around Willy
Nilly,
then a certain point it's like,
okay,
it's the boy who cried wolf and the term
is a very broad term.
It someone's grandma's prejudice and
says,
I don't want my grandkids,
you know,
dating a black person that's not the
same as advocating genocide
and they're both racist,
but you can't regard them as synonymous
at one.
Doesn't necessarily lead to the other.
Yeah,
yeah.
It's the fact that racism.
I mean I think that racism has probably
diminished somewhat.
Would you agree with that in terms of
like between now and say like when we
were.
What year were you born?
[inaudible]?
Seventy six.
Do you think from 1976 to 2018?
Racism in this country is diminished or
enormously?
Enormously.
Yes,
I think so.
I think it's.
I,
I'm from Brooklyn,
right?
So I don't really have friends who are
like waspy white people.
I can't imagine a situation where people
are hanging out and saying racist
things.
Connecticut.
No,
but I mean I can't imagine them sitting
race thing.
Everyone's looking at them like they're
not crazy.
Like it would just be so shocking and I
think 40 years ago that wouldn't be that
uncommon.
It would happen.
I think there's also the reality of
social media is that there are
absolutely real repercussions for any
sort of racist out al.
Yes.
AnYthing you say?
Anything that's any,
any outburst,
anything that you say that in terms of
like dis you could if you're somewhere
and you say something publicly that's
racist,
someone could tweet that and it will
ruin your life so we could post that on
facebook and it would ruin your life and
I think that keeps legitimate racists
from being as out with it,
which reduces racism overall because I
think when less people are doing it,
it seems less culturally acceptable and
then people change the way they think,
but it's also.
It's eAsier to be racist when you're
only talking to people who are like you,
but if you're interacting with people
from all over the world and you're like,
okay,
this guy's a putz,
but he's also like the people I know.
It's very hard to maintain that
prejudice when you're seeing people who
are acting similar to you because it's
anonymous behind the screen and if they
turn out to be black.
I was like,
okay,
this guy's not different for me.
Yeah.
That's the interesting difference
between New York and los angeles is the
fact that in New York everybody
integrates with everybody on the street.
They're all walking together,
they're all getting on subways together.
They're in buildings together.
Everybody's walking around together like
it's all black and white and brown and
yellow and everybody's together and la
man,
everyone is in their cars and they'd go
from cars to their houses.
They go for their houses to their work
and there's a lot of segregation just in
terms of people just not interacting
with other people in a normal day to day
commuter type situation.
That my second favorite city,
even better than New York about this,
which is toronto because everyone's
walking on the street,
looks like the un,
so it's.
And they're very,
very integrated and very cool.
I love that city.
That's a great city.
Yeah,
it's too fucking cold.
I've never been there in the winter,
so I've been there in the winter.
Is that bad?
It's rough.
OkAy.
It's fucking cold,
but.
But it's a really great city.
That's.
That was the last stop on my tour.
Oh,
before my netflix special was toronto.
When you're in toronto and you're from
brooklyn,
you are the coolest person in the whole
city.
Everyone,
I tell you,
like at least five or six people made a
point telling me like,
oh,
you're from brooklyn.
Oh,
I've been to williamsburg and I'm like,
do you think this is like you're a
mecca,
like there's a giant stone cube that
you're all worship thing.
And the brooklyn pizza in toronto is
excellent.
I went in there and being like,
you guys are assholes.
I try to go,
nope.
Excellent.
And oh,
speaking of innovation,
there's this restaurant there called the
black hook.
How did you go?
No,
they take awful meet f a l,
Oregon meat,
and they make it all gourmet and
amazing.
And I was there and like the creativity
in every dish.
I was like,
holy shit,
this place is amazing.
Oh,
interesting.
Great place.
There's a lot of great restaurants
there.
It's just a great international melting
pot,
like a legit melting pot.
And it's really funny for me as a troll
because they're all passive aggressive.
Right?
So you can poke their buttons and get
them to lose their shit.
Uh,
it's,
it's hard to do,
but when you get the canadians freaking
out,
it's really fun.
You're one of the rare,
happy,
intelligent,
well educated,
successful people who also considers
themselves a troll.
yeah.
Yeah.
I guess that's pretty rare.
Yeah,
because you do it with a smile on your
face.
And in my heart is a genuine playfulness
to it.
Yes.
Right.
We're,
whereas a lot of people,
if there's a bitterness and resentment,
if someone doesn't agree with me or I
don't agree with them or if I don't like
their music or their tv,
I wish them well.
I wish their family will just because we
can't be friends as it means something
bad should happen to you.
And most people can wrap their heads
around that.
Like if they think you're a different
political person for me,
I want you to die.
It's like,
no,
I want you to be.
Well just we don't have to be friends
and that's okay.
So it's fun fucking with people.
Well my favorite one was talking about
how trump wants to build a wall in the
south.
Hitler built the berlin wall,
wake up people and don't like hitler did
and while I'm like,
well,
he wrote about it in my comp.
They had the blueprints in it and they
start arguing for days.
They'll argue with me.
It's amazing.
We'll some arguments do go on for days.
I follow a few arguments that I'm not
involved in and I'll just go and dip my
toe and I'm like,
you guys are still going to add like
christ,
don't you have shit to do?
Yeah,
it's fun trolling people until we also
take into account the sheer amount of
time and constructing these zingers and
these,
these paragraphs and then then googling
the facts and then posting relevant
studies and the fact that people just,
they'll,
they'll obsess on it.
You know,
they're not just obsessing about it when
they're sitting right there probably at
restaurants talking to their spouse,
just twisting it up in their head and
trying to figure out a way to win.
I don't argue with people really.
so if they come at me and they asked me,
well,
how about when you think about this?
I just go,
am I being detained?
Like that's all I say,
and then that's it.
I'll just say nah.
And that's it.
Why?
Yeah,
but you like to fuck with them?
I do like to fuck with them.
Why do you like to fuck with them?
Is it because they're non player
characters and you want to wind them up
and have bouncing off the walls in a
liquor store that you don't have to
visit it anymore?
That that's part of it.
That could be part of it.
I think it's just,
it's it,
it makes me.
It's funny to me how life is a great fun
adventure or you've worn many hats in
your life,
so vi,
right?
And you never know what's gonna happen
next and if you have the sense of
appreciation and joy for it,
I think that's the best and right
attitude.
If you take everything.
So some,
some,
some blue checked asshole speaking
myself on twitter is wrong.
how does that affect you?
Fine,
I'm an asshole.
What do you care?
So it's very funny to me how easily
people flip their shit.
And this is the one how people who are
marginally intelligent think they're
brilliant and how quick they are to
assume everyone around them is a moron.
Everyone is ignorant of 99 percent of
human knowledge.
And just because someone smarter than
you doesn't mean they're going to be
writing an argument.
They might not have access to data you
have or they might not just not see
something,
but people who are marginally
intelligent think they know it all.
It's like,
no,
you don't,
you know,
almost nothing.
And as,
as do all of us.
Yes,
that's a really good point.
Most people know almost nothing about
everything.
correct.
And that's okay.
Doesn't make them bad people if you
don't know how to spell that.
Okay.
That's such a great point because lack
of information does not mean lack of
intelligence.
Right?
And,
and,
but also presence of intelligence
doesn't mean presence of information.
Right?
Or presence of information doesn't mean
the presence of intel.
Correct.
Yeah.
That's.
This is why my show is misspelled.
It's called your welcome while you are.
And people correct me,
but they're actually wrong because the
first thing I say is I'm michael malice
and let this be your welcome.
So they're wrong on every level,
but they still got to jump in.
Kennedy just re tweeted it out.
You're welcome.
You know?
And then if people are correcting her,
I'm like,
don't you think maybe an author and
brooklyn spelling bee champion.
Thank you very much.
Yes,
I in brooklyn.
I've the jacket if fits now.
Don't you think?
Maybe I know the difference in your,
in your maybe what year were you?
What year was this?
80 five.
And you were brooklyn and we know.
How old were you?
A nine.
The,
the jacket still fits.
It fits now.
It didn't fit then.
Oh,
it was too big.
Yeah.
Oh,
okay.
I see.
I grew a little bit.
So they gave you a jacket.
They get a jacket and athletic stating
that you would fit into it eventually?
No,
everyone gets the same size jacket
because it's from like age or maybe it
was 10.
It was fifth grade.
So it's like 10 to 14.
One size fits all the daily news.
So if you were a football player or if
you were a nerd,
there's no skillful players in the
spelling bee.
I should not one.
Not one.
So that approaches on your part against
football?
No,
I just,
I was there and none of them were.
I'm sure there were no shoulders to be
had.
No,
no,
no brush shoulders at the madison square
garden in 1986 or something like that.
Yeah.
Wow.
You were in madison square garden?
Yeah,
that's right.
It was.
Wow.
Not really.
I mean it was like a small part I guess.
Yeah,
it,
you know,
there's like the big part of madison
square garden.
This is the smallest theater.
Yeah.
So there's a smaller one.
It was more than one theater in madison
square garden.
It was a tiny one because we did our,
we did a theater really small recently
where there was a ufc press conference
and then a way in and that was not that
big.
That was with that.
Was that,
was that with matt hughes?
No,
no.
That was a different one.
That was just last weekend and that was
a tiny one.
I want to say it looked like it was no
more than maybe a thousand,
1500 people.
It seems small,
you know,
it seems like a small little.
Maybe it's called the hulu.
Okay.
How many seats does that bad boy?
I want to say 2000.
I'm going to go with 2000 because I've
done the other one which is 6,000
5,500.
Is it really?
Wow.
That's a joke.
That's crazy.
So there's more than one theater though,
but there's the big theater and then
there's more than one little theater or
am I wrong?
Think so,
but the little one that you're talking
about doesn't really come up because
there's not tons of events at it that
like write tickets all the time.
Man.
It dIdn't look like 5,500
people.
it looked way smaller than that.
I don't know.
I could be wrong,
but still.
That's pretty dope.
When fucking spelling bee champion,
did you stick it in everybody's face for
a couple of weeks afterwards?
They might have had a day in my honor at
my elementary school.
Wow.
Because that was the first one to ever
do that day in your honor.
The chicks look at you differently.
Do you remember this?
Uh,
no.
What's your recollection have any effect
at all?
It was still tough.
Total disdain?
Yeah.
Does it help being on fox news?
The chicks look at you differently
because of that.
Not in a good way.
Here's the,
here's the problem.
When you're on tv and doing panels and
things like that,
you're talking to women who are not only
beautiful,
they're also extremely well spoken and
great conversationalists.
The percent of human beings who are good
conversationalist is like one percent,
so it's very hard to date because it's
like,
I don't care about sheila in your office
and how she's giving you headaches so it
fucks you up.
And it's also hard to meet people
because you know,
you meet people in green rooms,
but it's hard for me to meet people day
to day.
Yeah,
it's tough.
It's hard out there for a pimp saying,
let 10 had strong joe.
It's going to be hard for those gals
too,
right?
Yeah.
well no,
they could probably take the wall street
guys.
Yeah,
but do they want to.
I mean if you're a super smart,
really articulate woman who's also has a
career of her own and then you've got to
pretend you're dumber than this dude,
cause you got to be smart and funny,
but you can't threaten his male ego.
No,
I'm impressed with so many of those
women.
I mean because they got to look amazing
and they're also funny and quick on
their feet and in informed the,
they've got the whole fucking that I
have to ignore that breeze going in
between their legs because he's not
wearing any pants.
I've,
I've got to sit in a lecture once.
it was one of the great bucket list
moments of my life.
Yeah,
the lecture.
yeah,
yeah.
My quads are important.
So fox news switched the fucking game,
didn't it when it comes to that?
Yeah.
They can wear pants now.
Well it's not just that I'm saying that
having really hot women talk about
policy
talk about.
Well yeah,
that was roger's innovation and that's
the big mistake.
I think they get a bad rap because it's
like,
oh,
they're just a bump,
like bubble heads.
These women are very smart.
Don't curse the haglins.
She,
uh,
she was mIss America.
She was on a lot of shows with me.
You win miss America because of also
being able to speak well.
It's not just how you look in a bathing
suit.
These women are all type a
overachievers.
They're still having miss american now,
but now they don't wear bathing suits.
Right?
Oh god.
This is one of the jokes that got
caught.
Can I tell this joke?
I just told her yesterday,
lucky scent.
I was on kennedy show and they were
cutting the bathing suit from miss teen
usa.
And I said,
can you ask the producers if it's okay
for me to say jonbenet ramsey spinning
in her grave?
And candy goes?
No,
like,
no.
So I couldn't say that joke.
That's a rough one.
That's a good one.
Good one.
I was in dallas once and uh,
me and joey diaz and duncan were there
for a standup and uh,
we were staying at this hotel and in the
hotel they were having a little kid
beauty contest and it was fucking twist.
I'm talking like five,
six year old girls wearing high heels,
paint makeup,
full horror paint.
Yeah.
Full warpaint.
They look like drag queens.
It was so,
but it was just strange.
It was like they were impersonating
grown women.
Right.
And there's a and very sexualized.
It's so creepy to see them.
Little tiny girls were little tiny feet
trying to walk around and stiletto
heels.
Right.
And bras and skirt.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
It's,
it's,
it's very weird fucking twisted man.
Yes.
It's twisted.
Is it,
do they look even more fucked up in
person?
Yeah.
Then on tv.
I'd never seen it in person before.
And then to be around them like you feel
scared or.
you know what I mean?
It's like I don't,
I've never seen this in real life.
Oh,
it's fucking strange.
We were passing by this ballroom where
it was going on,
so they were all milling out into the
hallways and we were walking through and
I was like,
this is fucking strange.
There was so many of them and you know,
and it's like these fat mom's that look
like a mama june.
That's what they look like.
They all look like that and they're all
look strange and they have too much
lipstick on and you know,
and they're wearing weird clothes
themselves and they got their little
kids dressed up like grown women.
It's like,
whoa.
Yeah,
it's,
it's upsetting.
And they're also the.
And the thing is even if they're not
wearing the makeup,
it's still extremely competitive and
you're fucking with the kids' emotions.
Yes.
Yeah.
And it's competitive in a way that
you're basically just judging them on
their physical presence and maybe some
fucking shitty singing they're doing.
Yeah,
it's,
it's.
And for what,
what did the tap dance or something,
what do they do?
Tend to do things like that,
like this kind of stuff,
but that's even more a tween I think
at that bad grandpa.
Oh,
this is real bad grandpa.
that was hilarious.
And this.
But these are real.
A real content is a real contest there.
Bud out and turn this off and at that
frosted hair.
good lord.
It's best highlights from mom.
Yeah.
That's one of those weird traditions
where people are going to look back in
the future and they'll go,
what the fuck were people thinking?
Do you know?
When I had her on my show,
miss America,
I asked her a quiz that miss America
questions.
There used to be a rule that I think is
rule like 14 or before miss America had
to be of the white race.
Whoa.
Yeah.
Until not that long ago.
Really?
And they have to approve it.
I think the fifties or sixties.
It was.
It wasn't like the twenties.
No,
no,
no.
Yeah.
And there was drama with bess myerson.
Who's the first and only today jewish
miss America.
What was the drama like?
She's jewish.
I think they asked her to change her.
They asked her to change her name.
Oh yeah.
This was what?
Something maybe smith something.
Yeah,
something.
A little less ethnic.
Something white.
Yeah,
what year was that?
I mean I think she's the forties where I
looked up sheryl brown in 1970 was the
first black miss America after they
abolished the rule that rule number
seven that was instituted during the 19
thirties.
That contestants must be of good health
and the lack of white race.
Her name's brown too,
but you can't change that name.
I mean,
that's her name,
which she is the whole package.
There she is.
Miss America is this,
uh,
this time.
I mean,
I know you enjoyed chaos.
Oh,
I love it.
And you enjoy.
You enjoy watching ships and fools
crashed into rocks.
Oh yes.
You really do.
Well,
is this time fruitful for you?
Oh my god.
Is this,
it gets better and better everyday.
I wake up and I feel like I'm in the
smurf village or something.
I'm so happy all the time.
But do you have any concerns that this
is going to go horribly wrong and we're
going to wind up in a nuclear war with
Russia or nothing?
No,
no,
no.
I mean,
there were,
there are many times when we could have
been a nuclear war with Russia during
the cold war and they were actually
stopped there at these great stories
about that,
like the submarine and the,
of course,
the cuban missile crisis.
Uh,
I have no concern actually both reagan
and gorbachev,
this is a great story of history
independently were taken to the bunker
and walk through and both of them refuse
to press the button.
Even as simulation.
They both said,
if we get nuked,
we get nuked.
I'm not fucking retaliating killing
millions of people.
So I think this idea,
remember the,
the idea that trump has his finger on
the nuclear button,
he's going to be nuking people all the
time.
It's like he's never gotten a fistfight.
So it's going to be,
you know,
it takes a lot to nukes,
you know what I mean?
The only countries ever knew anyone was
us.
Let's remember that.
Do you remember him threatening joe
barden sort of job on him?
Yeah.
And then he said,
I would knock you out,
joe biden,
joe biden would go down fast and hard.
So he said,
I talked about in the beginning of my
netflix specials because it was so
ridiculous.
I was like,
I want to get in his ear,
try to make this happen.
like you're great at everything.
You'd be great at fighting.
Yeah.
Do it.
Do it,
do it.
They'll let it talk to you.
Making fun of your kids to old men like
trump and biden.
Fight to the death.
It would be amazing.
It would probably be the biggest paper
view event in the history of the world
have been.
Well,
what?
What's currently the biggest pay per
view?
Many pack yow.
A floyd mayweather.
The first fight.
This would clearly when.
Yeah.
oh,
I saw these old guys go at it.
Yeah.
They're so old too.
It's like back in Russia,
lane motherland.
Look,
get these guys exist in Russia.
That grandpa's in it.
This was a real real fight.
Yeah.
There's a lot of that in Russia fell
when he hit him and then the other guys
like,
bitch,
I got you.
And then he falls.
That's how ruth bader ginsburg broke her
ribs.
They don't talk about that.
Yeah,
she fought with some other bitch.
Tried to pull a knife on her.
Oh,
you have to do is have good movement
because it's got a good job,
but he's got no balance.
Hips are bad too.
Oh,
leg kick.
Like synchronized.
No,
like modern dance.
this is real old dudes.
Guys got no shoes on too.
That's probably why he's doing better.
The guy with no shoes does grounded
better calling this fight like you have
got the vest.
He's thinking about sucker punched him
with the right.
See?
See,
I saw that comment.
See I saw that right?
Karate chop.
Karate chop during the face.
But you could see the guy tightening up
with that right side.
You got to be real careful when you see
a guy moving funny with that car looked
like it was a key.
I think it said.
Do you know where this is?
man just had like a european man statue.
This has got to be some european
country.
Mm.
There's a twitter account,
like something only in Russia and it's
just rushing shit.
I look at it,
I'm like,
fuck,
this is my jeans.
Yeah,
you got crazy jeans,
man.
I'm rushing.
People have done some wild shit.
It's like dan soders joke about russians
are the scariest white people.
It's say he,
that's his job.
He has this whole bit.
He goes,
uh,
I,
I moved to bed.
I'm going to butcher it because I'm not
a comedian like dan.
But he goes,
you know,
I moved to this neighborhood and I
figured out what to do.
He goes,
someone came up to me.
He's like,
yeah,
motherfucker,
what the fuck you doing?
He goes,
you think this is about neighborhood?
And he goes,
I just put on her russian accent and
really scattered rays like russians are
the scariest white people.
They're definitely not regular white
people and the women are the worst.
Are they russian winning?
Then we'll fucking cut you and laugh at
your bleeding.
Whoa.
They're merciless.
My mom,
my grandma,
they would do enough fuck around deaf
from the old country.
What about Russia?
Woman that you encountered today?
They're worse because they're liberated.
So they're,
they're,
they're ruthless.
They're very hot.
Crazy in the head.
Crazy in the bed.
Yeah.
But I,
I can't do it.
Well,
that band that the documentary was the
pussy riot.
Those bitches are loped.
I got to put free pussy
riot tee shirt.
I don't even know what they did wrong,
but some wearing that shirt.
Yeah.
Well that's,
it's ballsy to criticize putin.
Oh yeah.
Yes.
That is.
I don't care if you're a band or you're
a journalist,
like whatever you're doing.
That guy has killed a lot of people and
laughs about it.
Yeah.
You know the super bowl ring story.
No,
you don't want to hear this.
Oh,
find google it.
So I don't fuck up the stats because a
sturgeon simpson actually told me this.
The,
um,
there was a super bowl winner who
visited putin and as he's talking to
putin,
putin asked him to see the ranks.
You've got the super bowl ring and a
putin holds onto it,
puts it on his finger and walks away.
And then the guy starts going,
hey,
that's a vote in putin's bodyguards.
Put their hand on a guy like,
no.
So over.
Oh my god.
You fucking ring.
Yes,
my friend sandy.
While we're just given out a sandy my
ring and he said,
why don't you show it to the president,
showed it to him and he put it on and
kept it.
He helps his version of it there.
There's a version of it in an actual
article that's more detailed where he
talks about how they,
you know,
he asked for it back and they were like,
no,
here's what happened.
The other thing is how he traveled
Angola,
merkel,
you know this story now,
angela merkel is headed german,
chancellor Germany.
She's terrified of dogs,
so he brings out his giant,
like black lab,
which are the sweetest braid and this is
look up merkel put and dog and she's
sitting there terrified to look at it
and the dog sniffing her.
It's like a lab and he's just sitting
there fucking laughing like an asshole.
And he's like,
oh,
I didn't know.
She was scared of dogs for like how many
world leaders that you're bringing your
dog out to meet other than her and the
body language and her.
Yeah,
look at her.
She's freaking the fuck out.
Oh look at her.
And I was scared of dogs either,
by the way,
at a lab.
Come on.
Yeah,
fucking weird.
Look at her.
She's like,
ah,
not fart in Ireland.
That was so funny.
Yeah,
he's an asshole.
He's,
um,
it's,
it's very strange what he's been able to
do.
Oh yeah.
Did you see the assassination attempt
where the guy drove into his car full
clip,
changed lanes on the highway and went
into the oncoming lane into the fast
lane on the other side.
Full clips slammed into his car and
killed his driver.
But he wasn't in the car.
Oh my god.
No,
it's wild.
It's wild.
It was an assassination attempt and they
just didn't know that he wasn't in the
car.
But the fact that they were able to cut
through the lanes.
Yeah.
Get into the center where,
you know,
they're there,
they have access to the oncoming lanes
and pick his car right out of all the
car.
Meaning it had to be coordinated with
someone.
Right.
Because there's got to be a motorcade,
right?
Because.
Well,
they're out here.
Wow.
Oh,
that's it already.
just keeps running it by.
Oh,
but just do it from the beginning.
The beginning wasn't gold.
There's a better version of it.
Then there's a better version of it out
there and the better version of it.
You see the guy changed lanes.
Foam.
Yeah.
And slam in and had to know that that's
where his car was.
Killed.
Him.
Killed the driver,
but putin was not in the car,
but it was putin's car.
He's magic.
Well,
he just knew something was up.
I mean he must have a bunch of people
feeding them information all the time.
And how many assassination attempts have
there been on that guy?
Well,
I mean,
what about the assassination of sun on
the presidents that we don't hear about?
Both obama and trump.
There have been plenty.
Really?
Yes.
But what ones do you look at?
I mean they just trump.
Yes.
Really?
A red horse.
Yes.
I haven't heard anything of course,
because they don't want to talk about it
[inaudible] then he hit the victim and.
And also you don't want to get these
people's attention.
In all fairness.
I think that's a good move to be like,
all right,
let's not talk about this.
Like you don't want to talk about when
terrorist attacks were foiled because
then they'll know,
okay,
this doesn't work.
We're going to try it a different way.
So that's smarter.
The press I think,
you know,
but
I mean he's been able to run Russia for
a long time.
Oh yeah.
I mean he had his number.
It was like teddy roosevelt and taft.
He had his number two there was terminal
and mitzi goes,
you're gonna be president.
I was like,
okay,
I'm done now I'm going to be back in.
The guy's like,
okay,
here you go mr putin.
But that's what's crazy is he got back
in and everybody's like,
okay.
And his approval rating.
so like 70 percent.
Something crazy there.
Some huge number of the russians love.
Do they love him or do they say they
love them because they're scared.
No,
russians love aggression.
We love someone who is nasty and an
asshole.
Why is the assassination attempt on
Donald Trump?
Bigger news.
What was the assassination attempt?
A 20 year old man in vegas pulled a gun
from a las vegas polIce officer and
tried to do a rally guy.
Boy,
don't tase me,
bro.
End of his life.
I,
I mean,
that's come on at 20 years old probably,
you know,
from britain,
I think you need overstayed his visa or
something like wow,
crazy man
wasn't he trumped just giving a talk and
there was a was trump and there was a
boom and he goes,
you missed.
He allegedly trIed to pull a gun from
the holster.
The police officer at a trump rally in
las vegas on saturday.
He was arrested and later secret service
that he had driven to the advent from
California and had been planning to kill
the candidate for a year.
So this was before he was president,
or maybe it's 2016.
June.
Yeah.
So a few months before the election.
But this.
There's been other attempts on him since
he's the president.
Yeah.
Other one says it was an isis attempt,
but this is from the daily beast.
So I don't know
how
well they're not going to be pro trump.
So if they're saying it,
I'm sure.
Yeah.
Well,
it's crazy that he wanted the job.
it's scary for mean.
I mean,
look at gabby giffords in Arizona.
I don't believe in voting,
but she had this tweet about like,
uh,
she went and voted and I couldn't think
of a better pro voting argument that she
kinda is like,
look,
you know,
you don't believe in voting voting.
Yeah.
Um,
what does that mean?
I don't believe in voting.
What do you mean?
I don't think it's,
I don't do it.
I don't,
I never wrote an article about it for
the guardian.
Uh,
I just don't think it's legitimate
voting democracy.
In what way?
in any way.
Like the idea that I flick a switch and
someone gets to talk to me for four
years,
taught for before years doesn't make any
sense.
What do you think the alternative should
be?
Freedom.
If I want to someone to speak for me,
I'll hire them.
And the idea that me and my neighbors
have to be locked into some policy
because we're geographically close to
each other.
His landline technology and a posts cell
phone world.
So how do you think things should be
run?
You organize based on how,
who you want to align with on any given
a context.
Like I'm aligned with macy's when it
comes to my clothes and I'm aligned with
you when it comes to talking.
You don't have to have one guy speak for
you for abortion and for uh,
the borders and for taxes.
I mean,
I don't believe in any of that stuff.
This is very old,
old model.
I agree that it's a very old model,
but the problem is we don't have any
other one.
Sure we do because one of the other 99
percent of our interactions are
voluntary and you come together with
people as you need to and then you go
your separate ways and it's very,
very dynamic.
So this idea that you're stuck with this
person because a lot of people like him
for four years and they speak for you.
It makes no sense to me.
It does not make sense,
but it's also we feel like we need some
sort of a representation of us.
If you're going to have some sort of a
summit with a guy like putin,
sure,
or someone kim jong moon or whatever it
is,
whoever it is,
someone needs to speak for us.
Sure.
Right,
and I mean in the sense that is a
reaction,
but the point is I don't.
The vast majority of people in this
country,
we're not a vast.
A lot of people say,
trump's not my president.
he doesn't speak for me and they have a
right to say that and the idea that just
because someone wins a contest,
therefore he's the boss of me.
Well,
what do you think about voting when it
comes to legitimate concerns?
Like raising the speed limit,
reducing taxes,
doing this,
doing that,
like fixing roads,
like certain things that we need to get
done.
I don't.
I don't do it.
I mean that makes more sense to me
because it's a direct representation,
but even that shouldn't be up to
majority rule.
I mean people who understand the
dynamics of speed limits in cars should
have informed say rather than.
Right.
But then there's influenced by the
insurance companies,
and this is why low rates,
this is why things changed,
but didn't she got lost.
But insurance companies are the ones who
have the campaigns to force people to
vote one way or another.
It's going to be one,
right?
One side's going to have much more like
marijuana laws,
you know,
and all these tobacco and alcohol
companies trying to make sure that
marijuana is not legal.
Uh,
and all these,
this propaganda you have because they
don't want competitors.
Would you rather have people be high
than drunk?
Like if dad's coming home from work,
I'd rather he had a joint that,
a six pack.
I mean,
and yet historically it's just because
alcohol has been popular.
That's what's legal.
It makes no sense.
No drunk driving versus driving stoned.
I mean,
one guy's going to slow the other ones,
you know.
Well,
one's got probably paranoid to and
checking every mirror,
checking a bag,
a cool drive slower,
slow down Cuba together,
writing the lines,
right?
Yeah.
I don't,
I don't think that the system that we
have now is great,
but to just not participate at all,
but I do participate.
Obviously if I'm a public figure and I'm
talking is participating,
so just discourse.
You have to some extent.
Yeah,
I mean I don't think the idea that
you're flicking a switch means you're
actually making a difference.
I think her doing something in secret
once every four years.
You're not actually participating.
That's something people like to tell
themselves.
It's like getting a communion wafer.
do you think that it's archaic also to
have this timeline of four years and
especially when it comes to like
registering to vote?
I think that's the most archaic thing
ever,
that you have to go somewhere to do it,
but meanwhile you have a driver's
license if you're driving around,
you have a driver's license.
If you have a driver's license,
you should be able to vote.
Sure.
Well,
not necessarily.
If you're a citizen now,
be a citizen to get it out and if you're
a citizen.
Yeah.
And your.
What do you think about criminals being
able to vote like this one that's a hot
topic?
Uh,
I,
I think that there should be more like
if you've done your time,
especially if I nonviolent crime,
right?
Uh,
I think what I'm really excited about
what happened in politics this week was
jeff sessions getting fired because he
wouldn't.
Let me.
ThIs is one of the reasons I hate the
press.
when kim kardashian went to the white
house,
they all clowned her.
Kim kardashians saved the lady's life.
She saved someone's life.
So unless you save a life,
shut the fuck up.
You went to the white house to talk
about prison reform and to talk about
people who are innocent in jail right
now.
And she brought the case to Donald
Trump.
Mandatory minimums.
And you tell that lady's family.
We saw the footage of them crying.
You tell them,
oh ha ha.
Kim kardashian.
Kanye west.
When he went to the white house,
he talked prison reform.
He said,
people who are not vial,
blah,
blah.
The point is it will be the greatest
thing for freedom ever if the republican
party,
traditionally law and order party,
we're in a position to be more liberal
about prison sentence thing because a
lot of these people don't need to be in
jail even if they need to be punished
and when you send someone to jail,
they're going to be terrorized and
raped.
I mean,
if someone's dealing weed,
is that really appropriate?
So sessions was when the big opponents
of this,
he's.
He thinks marijuana and heroin are
basically the same.
So if he's gone,
this is a great opportunitY for both
parties to work together and a lot of
these people do not need to be in jail
and it's expensive as fuck.
Yeah,
I,
I couldn'T agree more.
he also said something that was one of
the most ridiculous things I've ever
heard.
Good people don't smoke marijuana.
that's really.
Have you done a survey?
Like what the fuck?
What are you talking about?
Well,
he lives in some 19 fifties norman
rockwell painting,
but in the,
in 19 fifties,
there are good people who smoke
marijuana,
jack kerouac.
That's a good person.
But it's what I'm saying,
it's like he lives in an idealistic
portrayal of life,
not life itself,
but it's such blanket statements which
are usually a fan of.
But yeah,
like fuck you.
But he was an asshole long time ago.
I mean that guy has been a piece of shit
for a long time.
If you go back and some of his choices
and some of those decisions,
what decades ago,
he was thought to be too creepy for the
supreme court.
He was thought to be too creepy for
politics.
He was thought to be.
I mean,
he's just a scary guy.
Well Now he's gone.
Thankfully.
So I.
But people,
some people are supporting him.
Look,
the president forced him out.
Good.
If that's the best endorsement of trump
I fucking heard.
And what's amazing is like different
states.
Republicans supposedlY for the last
whatever decades were for states'
rights,
let's every state decide they can
compete.
We had that with marijuana legalization.
Son had full blown.
Some had medical,
some had none.
This is how it's supposed to work.
and sessions was one who was Like,
even though it's still ostensibly
illegAl at the federal level,
is that a sessions like,
fuck you federal overrides,
we're going to have these rates.
Why leave them alone?
Let them decide on a state level like
you said that.
But they never did it.
Right.
I,
I know a lot of pushback by trump.
Good.
I know obama actually did have some
rates.
it's just insaNe.
Like you were part of the tomb gang in
high.
In high school or college,
right?
Yeah,
they did have some raids during his
administration.
I was on a grand jury duty and I talked
to the whole jury to let people off
about a marijuana stuff because I'm
like,
you don't have to indict on this.
Like why?
Why do you want to ruin someone's life?
What was the jury?
Now you have a bunch of cases,
you know,
said I can't get into specifics,
but I was like,
people are from all walks of life are
very receptive to the idea of when you
think about what jail means,
uh,
it's so fucked up.
And people are just like,
well,
someone does something wrong.
They should be punished even if someone
should be punished.
The idea that that punishment should be
jail is not the same thing.
Right.
And if someone's not at wouldn't,
wouldn't it be better if they had house
arrest,
for example?
Why do you need them to be terrorized
and locked in with a roommate?
I don't want a roommate.
Well,
not only that,
a roommate who's also locked in the
cage.
Yeah.
And only around other males.
No,
it's dark.
And you know,
it goes back to what you're talking
about early about empathy.
Yeah.
And how important that is and about how
easy it is for people to just dismiss
people.
Right?
You know what they call today,
the cancel culture.
Like people just want things cancel and
just want things.
Shut them down.
Right.
Get rid of them,
forced them out.
Firearm,
take away his thing.
Takeaways,
gig.
I mean,
and then put them in jail like this.
Put them in jail thing.
To me it's like here's a big one.
Taxes.
Like if you don't pay your taxes,
that put you in jail.
What a child support.
Yeah.
Like there was this meme I saw were like
a woman doesn't pay child support.
She gets the government,
she gets an apartment and if a guy
doesn't pitch outs where he goes to
jail.
Yeah,
yeah.
And you can't earn any money from when
you're in jail and all that money when
you get out who's that helping?
And it's going to help someone that
their dad's a jailbird now is it because
the resources aren't available to force
the person to pay like there's not
another.
So they try to make the punishment as
terrible as possible so that you
motivate them to shore.
But at a certain point it's like it's.
I don't think it's a conscionable to
really be sending a jail is so bad.
It really needs to be someone who's a
danger to society if they're walking
around.
I agree.
Um,
and again,
even the Martha Stewart model,
it would be so much happier for a lot of
these people were just locked in their
house.
Yeah.
Why do They need to be able to go to
jail?
Yeah.
But afterwards I've actually had the
ankle bracelet,
like why is that?
like once you start asking those
questions,
what will matter for you if it's an
ankle bracelet or if they're in jail,
would it matter that you've put them on
some island and they couldn't do that
and then people don't even think in
those terms.
Well,
because you lose your humanity once
you're a criminal,
it's like you're not a human being and,
and it's,
it's,
it's wait until wait until there's a
joke that like a conservative as a
liberal who's been mugged and a liberal
is a conservative who's had interactions
with the law.
It's like once you interact with the
law,
my friend ally's oral and she's a public
defender.
She is great.
It's like it's really easy once the eye
of sauron is on you and you're a
criminal,
shit goes out the window really fucking
quick and it's very scary.
Right?
And there's people that are prosecutors
that are trying to win.
They're trying to win a case and that's
what their job is.
Their job is not to make sure that
everything is being done correctly and
that you are being represented
accurately and that.
No,
no,
no.
The,
the,
the job is there is a case,
the cases against you,
you're on trial when the trial,
right?
That's my job.
It's a game and it has to be their job.
Yes.
Well,
it becomes a game.
I mean that.
This is the problem that I've said with
law enforcement period.
When cops see people,
They think of those people as a possible
arrest and there's a game and they've
been lied to.
By so many people.
I mean,
you're a cop.
You're dealing with people all day long.
They're lying to you.
You meet some new person.
You automatically assume they're lying
to you as well,
and then things get weird.
There's a great video called do not
cooperate with the police and it was
like a law professor,
I believe,
and he had the cop standing right next
to him.
He told the cop anything I say that's
wrong.
Please jump in and correct me and his
broad point,
I'll just sum it up quickly is you can't
talk your way out of an arrest,
but you can talk your way into one,
so he's like,
do not ever talk to them.
Just say thank you.
I know you're doing your job,
but I can't cooperate until I have an
attorney present because there's no
upside.
And then.
And they'd say to you explicitly,
anything you say can and will be used
against you if like,
hey joe,
can I borrow that screwdriver?
I can and will use it against you.
No,
you cannot borrow my scrEwdriver.
I need my eyes.
Yeah.
The,
the ultimate legal case.
Public legal case.
Uh,
or one of the ultimate ones is julian
assange.
Oh yeah,
that's a weird thing.
He hasn't seen sunlight and months.
No.
Internet access.
yeah.
They showed them the intimacy.
Yeah.
And they're trying to kick them out now.
Ecuador.
But where's he to go?
He,
if he goes,
he's good at what they want them.
What?
Sweden.
They want him.
They want him in britain and I don't
think they've been charges filed against
him here yet,
technically,
but I'm sure that they want his head on
a platter to what they want him for.
So preposterous.
It's so nice.
It's like a wannabe capone.
Yeah.
Excavation instead of being a mobster.
Right?
Yeah,
but it's.
It's interesting because I would think
that someone like trump who is such a
conspiracy minded person would actually
like juliana massage because I'm sure
there's been.
I mean,
I don't know what he's ever said in the
past.
He was anti wiki leaks from the start.
No,
but I.
He said things about juliana signs that
were anti.
That's my understanding.
Yeah.
That's because there was something
julian assange tweeted,
my friend,
cassandra fairbank's,
she's a big support of him and she's
like,
well,
there goes to the idea of clemency or.
Pardon?
Oh really?
Yeah.
So trump tweeted,
or julian,
I think.
Yeah.
It's a piece of praise.
The virtual prisoner.
Yeah.
It's like,
where's that end?
It's not gonna end.
Well,
he can get visitors though.
I don't can anderson.
Oh,
that's right.
Yeah.
Well,
but they may have taken that away.
Taking that away.
I wonder how long he could stay there.
That it's been years.
Years.
It's been years.
Years to be in one building.
Yeah.
And he,
he doesn't go outside anymore.
He can't,
they won't let them.
I don't think.
I don't think he ever could.
Went on the balcony.
Okay.
Now I know he doesn't see sunlight that
I'm positive.
That's terrible to they given vitamin d
at least.
No.
Yeah,
I dunno.
I mean he's awfully pale to begin with,
but if you don't get vitamin d like you
can get really sick,
but that's what they do in North Korea.
They get our skin starts falling off
there.
Has been there since June 19th of 2012.
We entered the embassy at six years.
Whoa.
Christ.
How much?
Almost six and a half years.
June.
How much solitaire can you play and you
don't even have internet anymore.
He isn't an internet for how many months
I'm looking at.
I want to say it's about him.
About four or five months.
It's been awhile.
I think it was March 27th.
They were suspended for eight months for
the second time.
It's October,
2016.
Fuck.
Who the hell's over at?
Wiki leaks.
Still running shit.
The intern who's hanging in there,
you know,
god.
That's crazy.
Like how does that one play out?
I mean they're,
they're,
they're really what they're doing for
sure.
When we're talking about punishment
being a deterrent and certain
situations.
That is absolutely a deterrent.
Oh,
they're making an example of him for
whistle blowers.
Oh yeah.
Whereas chelsea manning's out now.
She just had her surgery.
What surgery though?
Per transgender.
She got there.
She tweeted out.
I have,
I have a vagina.
Oh,
okay.
Yeah.
WeLl there you go.
Yeah,
she's out.
She's out.
Hobnobbing and maybe using that thing.
I met her.
She came to an event.
She was very nice.
Very sure.
But she's out.
She's out.
She's been out for obama.
Pardoned her computer.
Her sentence.
He's locked away forever in the embassy.
And then there's snowden.
Who is also hiding in Russia.
Right?
What actually a lot of these.
Yeah,
there's paula.
After almost a decade of fighting
through prison.
The courts,
a hunger strike and through the
insurance company.
I finally got surgery this week.
Not lasik apparently.
Oh,
you suddenly switch just wearing glasses
folks.
Um,
it was a mill house is going to be in
Russia probably forever eight.
Had a lot of these farmers from South
Africa.
That's where they're going to.
Russia.
Putin is letting them in.
Really?
Yes.
So they better learn how to write those
arms backward pretty quick.
Oh right.
They got weird ours.
Yeah.
Well you have to learn the whole,
the whole language and just a weird art.
It's just you guys.
Russians got a lot of weird ones.
So we do.
We got barely literate in Russia.
The letters look fake letters are fake,
but they look like alien language,
you know,
it was like somebody writing something
that is a piece of metal from a
spaceship like snowden is.
He's fucked too.
Right?
I mean he can't even be public in
Russia.
I'm not sure about him.
I know,
I know.
It sounds.
I haven't been following stoughton.
He's deep under when they must know
where he is though.
I mean there's no,
with the intelligence community is,
doesn't have a fucking full line on
exactly where that guy is.
The question,
do they know all this stuff or are they
incompetent?
And there's examples of both directions.
Yeah.
I got to think they know where snowden
is.
Like glenn greenwald talks to them all
the time.
Glenn greenwald in Brazil.
Yeah.
That was,
had gleaned,
kind of made his name.
I think he's also a great lefty who gets
that a lot.
Yeah.
um,
that's just.
How does that guy go on?
Like is he just in hiding,
getting his restaurants?
Like sneaking in,
like where?
Where does he get glasses?
How does he get around?
Yeah.
I don'T know who wants to get his money
from?
He's got pay for food.
Right?
What does he do for food?
Yeah,
a lot of borscht.
Fuck,
I just looked them up.
Google is like kind of broken.
here's an example of it.
It says when did he die?
And then it just highlights a date and
it doesn't say he's not dead.
So snowden flew to Hong Kong where he
was staying.
No,
but that was part of his whole trip.
He had to go through this whole journey
through a bunch of countries.
Yeah,
that's weird.
I think they tapped her to Thailand or
something at some point.
It is weird.
It's like,
is that guy just.
That's him forever.
That's what he does.
Who?
Snowden.
Yeah,
I mean he just has to hide.
I,
I think so.
Or maybe he safe and Russia and putin is
having him there as a fuck you to us.
Yeah.
I mean it must have something to do with
the putin's deciding to do this.
Putting wouldn't do it unless there's
some advantage to him.
It's just,
it's just strange.
Strange.
These things are just these floating
like a den,
a little chapters.
So these stories,
they're just,
you know,
we all know about it,
but they don't get resolved well,
right.
There's a.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
they're just floating and it's just
thinking.
I mean this is why I talk about North
Korea all the time since I've been
there.
Everyone's still there.
Everyone I met and like think about six
years.
[inaudible] has been in that one
building,
six fucking.
It's so and all the people in jail also
who had been jailed for 60 years.
Just a.
We can't wrap our heads around that six
fucking year.
thinking about where you were six years
ago,
I'm thinking of where I was six years.
Not just that,
like six years and things are
deteriorating.
Right?
They want them out of the embassy.
He's got nowhere to go.
If he leaves,
he gets arrested.
He doesn't have any internet.
Yeah.
Can't see sunlight knowing that the most
powerful people in the world were doing
everything they can to fucking put you
in jail for life and you kind of already
are in a sense.
I can't see julian assange is never in
the rest of his life.
Probably going to be able to like take a
jog around the park like ever.
No,
never.
We're like,
walk a dog.
Yeah,
it's over.
It's,
it's scary and the thing is a lot of
this shit that he.
Almost all the shit that he put out his
true.
That's what's crazy.
it's like he's doing what journalists
should be doing instead of getting up in
the press core and just pitching a fit.
Yeah,
but it is.
There's real repercussions for doing
what he did and that's what they're
letting us know and they're letting us
morning matter what the law is like,
what are you getting them for?
Secret sex or a surprise like what right
is running his twitter account.
He's the president of something called
freedom of press,
which is a website and twitter account
also have the same name and they tweeted
this out a couple of days ago.
Jet story I'd never heard of.
It says in the latest case in the trump
administration's cracked down on leaks.
Natalie edwards,
us treasury employee was arrested and
charged with giving suspicious bank
records involving trump campaign
associates,
paul manafort and rick gates to a news
outlet in the legal complaint,
the justice department said word for
word conversations he allegedly had with
the reporter over an encrypted messaging
app.
the government claimed it got ahold of
her phone and with it her encrypted
messages with a reporter.
Now she faces prison time.
Wow,
dude.
I'll report it should be using apps that
make all their messages disappear,
like signaling.
What's that?
Yeah,
that's what you use this website?
but even then someone can take
screenshots.
No,
I Think something that you can't.
It's disabled automatically.
Really?
Yeah.
But you can take a picture of your phone
with another phone obviously.
But signal.
Yeah.
My friend who knows more than anything.
I know that interest security.
He use signal signal and secure drop.
And so what is signal?
What do you do with signal?
Basically it's.
It's encrypted.
So if you send messages to me,
like you could set it to vanish at a
certain time and I can't do a
screenshot.
Oh,
interesting.
Yeah.
Hm.
And it's.
It's not hackable.
Apparently.
it's the best one.
It's the,
it's the better version of whatsapp.
What else?
Michael will have to discuss.
We can talk about we exactly already
3:00.
We can talk about my book when it comes
out that's coming on here.
When is your book?
May 14th.
What's it called?
The new.
Right?
Right.
Then you right.
What's the new,
right.
Then you write a nice way of saying
outright,
they're included in that.
Yeah,
I was charlottesville and I interviewed
some nazi store it.
What was that like?
A interesting.
How stupid were they?
Uh,
now,
not.
That's the big myth that these people
are affected because they're bright.
It's like any 90 percent what the nazis
iN charlottesville or bright.
Then in a hold on any population,
you can have 90 percent and it's 10
percent.
So there are people in that group who
are sophisticated.
This is whY they're getting traction.
You can just a kid but fucked up.
Correct.
Okay.
So evil geniuses,
uh,
I like to refer to myself as an evil
genius.
I don't know that I want to be lumped in
with that term,
but yeah,
I mean,
and I mean they're dangerous in that
sense.
They are intelligent,
manipulative,
and right.
And the thing is right and it's,
as soon as they start talking,
you see them as human beings.
It's very hard to dismiss people and
their ideas.
And if the press won't talk about those
ideas and sweep them under the rug and
they're saying things you've never heard
before,
right away,
there's an element of intrigue.
Well,
the right is such a dirty word now.
The right.
Like jusT saying,
it's always been a dirty word,
but was way dirtier now than it's ever
been before.
No,
no,
no.
In the past it was much worse.
Well,
maybe in my lifetime I should.
Yeah,
but I mean that there's a vested
interest on the part of the corporate
press to make it a dirty word because
then it's like,
well,
the all the good people are in the left
and then you don't have to do any
persuading.
Do you think that that's a strategy or
do you think that's really what evidence
do you have the points to it being a
strategy?
Because if you have news articles,
they will always use the term far right
as a pejorative.
They never used the term far left.
It's true.
It's a complete asymmetry and today for
sure,
and different countries,
you'll have all these nationalist
movements and they're always referred to
as far right.
Which is not accurate because they're
usually moderates when it comes to
things like social security or
government spending.
They're just on one issue nationalists,
but they're far right.
so that's a way to kind of lump them in
with the nazis.
And in many cases they aren't at all.
A nigel farrage is an example of this
hit when he took over ukip and the whole
british,
uh,
independence movement.
He fought against the white supremacists
because they wanted to tie together.
He goes,
no,
that's not what we're about.
And this was one of his big
accomplishments and doesn't get ever
getting credited about this while he's
just so inexorably connected to brexit.
Yes.
All anybody thinks about him as racism,
right?
That's by intent.
Yeah.
That's,
it's also just convenience,
sloppy,
lazy thinking by a lot of people were
just too many things to pay attention
to.
Right.
YoU kNow,
and if you just all brexit bad,
racist,
the definition of a racist is something
that a progressive doesn't like or
someone who's racist or someone is
racist.
So they're using these two things
interchAngeably,
but it's a problem.
That's the problem.
You can,
I remember when all used to be,
all used to be like nerds.
he used to be all left.
He used to be like alternative music,
all comedy,
all this.
But like sonic youth.
People don't say that anymore.
Like even in comedy,
they don't use the term alt rooms,
but all comedy was a thing.
Yes.
But now people stopped using it because
outright.
Yeah,
they just used the ucb like,
oh,
we're going to ucb.
They don't say I'm going to these rooms,
but sometimes people do refer,
like it's sometimes there's like a
little bit of residual leftover or some
comics will still use that word.
But alt.
If someone said,
oh,
he's alt,
you would automatically assume they were
like really low key left wing
progressive.
that was alt.
Now all is all right where it's like
racist nazi,
you know,
milo.
Well the npc script is right.
Like if a person is to the right of
hillary clinton,
then execute.
All right.
did ecc and I'm just giving you the
whole speech.
Yeah.
So it's,
it's,
uh,
I mean the discourse in this country has
completely collapsed and I love it.
Why do you love It though?
This course is because my rights are up
for discussion,
let alone a vote.
So whenever people sit down and have a
talk about my life and freedom,
it's going to end badly for me.
So if people can't talk to each other
about this,
maybe we'll go our separate ways and
live peacefully.
So you'd raTher not talk about it and
just go peacefully.
So what you're saying,
someone's political opinions and
preferences should have as much impact
in my life as their sexual preferences.
You want to fuck dudes.
You want to have a threesome?
I don't.
I care if you're my friend and that I'm
interested but it's not going to impact
me and it shouldn't impact me.
And same thing with,
oh You want more?
Well for grade go live your life.
That was sort of it becoming some
shouting match on your front door and,
and uh,
yeah.
instead of you and your buddies coming
up and scaring the shit out of my kids.
Yeah,
I mean no one.
I mean very few people deserve that.
I was going to say no one,
but very few people deserve that.
Yeah,
so disengaging from political discourse
as a strategy for just overall civility,
but also worsening political discourse
and a purpose to make it so that people
can't actually form coalitions and get
anything done.
But it is amazing how personal people
take other people's opinions on things.
Crazy.
People get,
you know what it is like when you're
dating and you think,
oh,
this,
this girl likes the same kind of music I
do,
so we're going to get along.
That is a very weak correlation and
there's lots of people who are right
wing who are good people and there's
lots of people who are left wing who are
good people and there's lots of people
who are right wing who are bad people.
There's a very weak correlation between
this.
Uh,
it's a cultural signifier.
You probably came from the same culture
because people just take the culture of
what they grew up with.
But if you're going to just dismiss it,
it's higher schools of thought.
Just because they vote dIfferently from
you is as a personal level that's you're
missing out.
A lot of quality people.
I couldn't agree more.
We should probably end it with that.
Tell me about your book.
When's it out?
May,
May 14th,
29.
Well,
that's a long time from now.
Come back on again when it comes out.
Yeah,
I love it.
I love you.
I love you buddy.
Thank you.
Alright,
bye everybody.
The.